Oh Christ.
He's all right.
All right, we're going live
now. Finally, here we go.
We had a just disaster trying to order
from the UFC TV app and then so we had to
go through your direct TV and then we
went to direct TV and then we had to call
in and they couldn't talk to a person. I
had to enter in shit, so I had a check.
Find my fucking account number
online. We all panicked. The debit.
We panicked a little bit but we're here.
Eddie Bravo's here. Ladies and gentlemen.
Hello. How are you doing
Brian? Motherfucker Collins
here. So everybody hell,
are you good to be a good to be here?
Brian bought wine.
That could be a good or a bad decision.
We're gone California first then we're
going to go a little Italy for my boy at
via Veneto courtesy.
Okay.
Fuck Riccio he's giving shout
outs already. We just started,
he gave me some great one.
Yancy Madeiros one already.
We didn't even get a chance
to watch the fight cause it.
We just just got it live and
printed motherfucking job.
What is going on with that shirt?
You are in like a 1980s he sure is movie.
Oh I'm glad you mentioned that Michael J.
Fox.
Well you look like a dude who's in
one of those breaking movie. Yeah,
everybody should have a Bandana.
Usually a tough guy with a
switchblade in an eighties movie.
That's what you should do.
A poor Mexican chicks wear jeans of that
material that they do do that swap in
right now cause that's just artificially
stretched in the extra e kids are
wearing it. They just
showed shogun. Did you,
have you seen the UFC light heavyweight
rankings? Yeah, he's like three.
It's kind of your Skype for four.
It's really crazy.
They're going to have that owes Demir
Dude, he's going to fight Jimi Manoa. Oh,
you're talking about
pound for pound champion.
He's had two fights in the UFC
and he's like number three now.
Weird light heavyweights. The
weirdest division. Jones out.
Kill it with John Jones out and Gustafson
obviously just rose to the top of the
heap. How good did he look?
God Damn. Wash that fight.
Which one? Gustafson and to share.
I missed that whole EOC. It was she,
I was on my way back down
to cost of sin was a Ninja.
It'd be tough to beat man.
Dude. He was so on point.
It was one of the best performances of
his entire career. It was incredible.
Those upper cuts. Oh my God.
Accuracy that heard c was insane.
I heard the fight companion, but I
didn't actually watch it happen. Dude.
He was amazing.
Gustafson was as good as he's APP.
I don't think he's ever looked better.
He's good.
He's gonna be a handful to beat for John
NDC. Yeah, he's, he's coming into his own,
you know, he's 30 years old
and fighting for a long time.
He said tough fights with John.
Tough fight with DC.
He got beat up by rumble, you know,
and he's took a long time off,
came back and look better than he's ever
lived. Has Knee, wasn't he for a second?
They're thinking about retiring
in his hometown. Just top on.
I bet you he's the light heavyweight
champ by the end of the year. He could be,
do you think he
beats John John's? Yup. Wow. Huh?
Who knows. Cause your brain guy,
he's the old shiny comes back.
We don't even know what John's
going to come back looking like.
The tide takes that much
time off and you know he's,
who knows either he's going
to come back better than ever.
Like Rory Macdonald looked and Bella tour.
Roy just needed rest though.
He's never looked like, you know
like Roy just need Resi rusted John.
He's a little cocoa, you
know, horror. Jeez. Hey pro
button ups and blazers talking about God,
I don't meet that.
I don't like that job. That's the OSP,
John. Those bullshit. You want that.
You want to relax John and
just doesn't devil may care.
I want the two day training camp.
John,
I wanted John to takes a flying knee for
his first opening movie going to show.
Yes,
he's 22 yes,
Britain does crazy elbows.
How about him?
Like bragging that he beat DC hi
coke a week before.
I don't think the best line of all time.
Best Line of all time. His career's
not going to be affected by that. No.
Right now we are accepted. He's, oh he's
the bad pile. The flow. He's the bad guy.
He comes clean. Yeah. Be
that guy fucking love that.
It's always better if
you come clean period,
because you can smell fakeness from a
mile away would be turns into Conner
McGregor,
but on Coke beat that guy.
I just think if you,
if you're,
if you're caught up in the demon in the
demons and if you're completely honest
about it, Americans love you.
They forgive the Shit Outta you.
Charlie's Shit fucked up again.
Exactly.
Charlie Sheen is like the
best example that ever.
Well who the fuck ever
admitted to doing crack? Yeah,
like on a regular basis and talking about
how he does it. I, that's how I do it.
That's how we roll and then he goes on,
it gets a TV deal for $900 million.
You're Robert Downey jr too.
Did he got the West TV? Yeah,
but he went to jail. He got cuffs
function. What's that raw iron man.
It was fucking, he shoes. Really?
He's Robert Downey jr it seemed when
I was growing up was in the news.
You always saw him in court for something,
right?
Robert Downey Jr was always asking
him for forgiveness for being awesome.
And then the judge
Robert Downey Jr is in court today.
He still mixing humongous Ironman.
Yeah,
we forgive drug problems easily.
It's when he got back he stuck movie
start with dudes who are drunks like an ex
cop and he gave up on life and he's just
a loser. He doesn't care about anybody.
Throws a pizza in a blender.
We root for Escobar.
When you watch,
when you watch narcos aren't
you kind of pulling forward?
You really want him to pull it out and
that's when you know somebody did their
job as a storyteller if you're at like,
it's like that's why science,
the lance was so genius because you
liked him and wanted him to be free cause
you were like, you know what he does,
he eat people but he wouldn't eat me.
Not only did everybody route for
Tony Montana, but what when I always,
anytime I would see that movie another
time I was hoping there would be some
kind of alternate ending.
I would always just leave
town to go back to your house.
Do you remember when, uh, we
will, uh, what's his face?
Is Larry David's show curb your
enthusiasm? Yes. Hear that crazy.
I had killer guy and he played, he
played in Scarface over his house. 24,
seven [inaudible] scarf.
He is 24, seven in his crib
and Rob Davis had Scarface.
Man. Scarface is a funny movie
and I know they're remaking it.
It's probably the first movie ever.
Would like an anti hero.
Was that the first one? Well No, not
the first one. The first big one.
But like Clint Eastwood movies are kind
of like that, right? He wasn't, yeah.
Clinics. What? It was like the high plains
drifter. He was kind of a Ne'er do well,
came back,
but he would do good things.
You wouldn't do shitty
shit is never a douchebag.
But the guy came back to life though. The
Godfather was, that was a, yeah, that was,
which was the one where he came
back to life, was it high plains?
He knows high plains drifter.
He came,
they beat him and whipped him to death
and he came back to life control a hitman
and he came back. Well, I don't
know that that was the case,
but I know that when high plains or did
he take your shirt off and he's got all
these bullet marks and the guy goes,
but you're dead.
We did meet him once and he's supposed
to be like a ghost came back and killed
everybody maybe to see if that's the case.
Do you mean you know he's sure that was
high plains drifter storyline was that
he was like, he came back from the dead.
It was a different person. Different.
I'm pretty sure I love that movie.
I only know Clint Eastwood from his
current movies. That was always old.
She never saw the outlaw
Josey Wales over shit.
That movie stands the test
of time. Oh, I'm young.
I'm not the best clinics would moving
high plan. I mean, uh, uh, I love jazz.
Who else? Man? It's pretty
close though. It doesn't matter.
It cannot come out before our time.
Honestly it was like in 1970 or something
like that. If it came out now it would,
it would still killed. I don't
know too much about Clint Eastwood.
I wasn't really into Westerns,
but I know there's a bunch you
hear Joey talking about and stuff.
I would be interested in and seeing a
documentary based on his career started.
It started with the good, the bad and
the ugly. It was the first I walk. Yeah.
And then how many did he
make after he made so many?
And here's the most of them in
Italy and more than that sheet what?
But here's the door call spaghetti
westerns because they were doing them in
Italy because they would,
they'd film in Italy and pretend
they were in New Mexico and she had
two of the most controversial
moments in movie history.
Clint Eastwood one is he rapes a woman.
He straight up rapes are in a barn.
He just,
he just rips a girl and he's a hero.
He's a hero.
And then the second
movie was that Hawaiians
drifter to, nope, it was at
that point with no Douche
bag in the movie. What movie?
It was just him as he was. He was just
a man. Just come that he raped a girl,
she and then she falls in love with and
then she calls them loving them later.
Okay, how about this? Ready? What is
this called? Then he can look past,
look at this through they're
making them do something to do is
they always check my toenails.
If you've got to trim your toenails,
do with a fucking toenail clipper
and then file that shit down. John.
Mike Winkeljohn doesn't have a
fucking eyeball because of that.
That's not oh shit.
True.
That is something very serious and should
have been taken care of a long time
ago. If I was fighting this guy and I saw
that he was doing that to his toenails
right before a fight with his fingers, I'd
be like, fuck no. He's using a clipper.
He's, he's, it is up to the point. He
sit down, it's a file it down sharply,
just trimming it and then on top of it
he's going to do the other toe to the
reps going to do it.
Now imagine if he'd go to fucking
refaced trim and his toenails. Man,
he's serious. This is crazy.
He's very religious. They should,
but they should be polished.
You should sand those fuckers down.
I agree with condoms all the time.
Many condoms on about it.
They're really, look fingernails.
Fuck People's eyeballs up. You know,
that's a big part of what's
going on with these IPOs.
It's not just a blunt object. It's a blunt
object with a fucking hard edge to it.
[inaudible] he goes, well,
he got poked in the US,
all three Gustafson and then he goes,
what? They go, can you see goes? No,
but I will keep fighting the old cool.
They'll let them fight off.
So I'm glad that it stopped the fight
and he goes, it wouldn't matter though.
He had my time and use faster, but
you know he had everything. Well,
if he couldn't see out of one eye,
that was,
he was getting beat up before that though.
But he did say he goes it,
it wouldn't matter. What
does it say? Jeremy?
I plains drifter had their rape and I
can't quite tell if this is the one,
how did the guys say?
Yeah,
that was the one of the reasons why he
got away with it because he was this guy
coming back from the dead. Well, what
is the, what is the, what's the premise?
So is that, uh, this at the
beginning of attractive towns,
woman deliberately bumps into him
in the street and Oxys to golf?
No, no, no, no. I don't mean
the premise of the rape. I mean,
the premise of the movie, I, it doesn't
really have, it's a long plot here. Okay.
Five paragraphs is insanely controversial.
He May,
there's a girl, she's about eight,
maybe younger. She saves him from a,
he's a union soldier. She saves him from
the confederate soldiers. He saves life.
She says, no, he's not here. And he
looks at her and cause he said, look,
he turns and kisses her on the lips
for about five seconds. How about that?
Oh yeah. More than that. It's, it's
like, you're like what? I mean,
they've got to witness on shit.
Yeah. But by the way, no, no.
It was a different movie and he in this,
he wasn't,
you knew he wasn't like a pedophile.
He was just so happy that his life had
been spared that you could never get away
with that. I probably shouldn't
it movies, but you know,
the 70s really crazy. It's like how
much culture has changed since 1970 yup.
How much humans have changed?
It's true.
I feel like Paulo here could rave or go
and get away with in the movies. I mean,
he is a dime pays and good luck on this.
Good fight before. No, it was a monster.
Yeah, he's very good. He's, he's
part pronounce his last name.
That's going to be tough.
You're asking the wrong gentleman here.
He's built like a, like a
speech. Congratulations.
What is a d? Jamie? See if you can
find the pronunciation of his name,
what we'll hear it from Brian Stann.
There's things that you
can do anymore nowadays,
but there's things now that you
couldn't do back then. Like,
Shit seems to be slipping into TV every
now and then and maybe a fuck after 10.
There's no, they're starting to
look at this. Did you see the lanes?
They were talking shit that to separate
them. Wow. Can I ask you guys a question?
Uh, who were in the know, I know
that you saw that is very strict,
but if you're in Brazil,
are you, uh, are, is there
literally just asked him a shingle
analysis? Let's say his name. Let's see.
What do you think of?
His name is Gina. Gina,
Gina, Gina, Gina,
and then his name is Olu la.
My mind,
I think it's been both. I think he's from
Nigeria. That's my guess. I think. Yeah,
let's hear it. Let's hear it. Give
me some volume. It'd be hilarious.
Flux and stuff. Oh, that's
here. I can't hear my,
here we go.
Let's hear the names a little louder.
Just all
Boshea bamboo. Bamboo shade.
Okay. Now listen to this
great fights.
That means drunk,
drunk chick or little drunk dude. Yeah.
For a cheap
drunk because I bet you this fight
doesn't get out of the first round, Jovan.
For Real. I don't think so.
The way the homeboy fights,
how much volume can we have
and still really what happens?
I mean the sound would get in
the, in the feed. Oh, okay. Right.
Then we get pulled on to
June's this Goddamn Youtube,
youtube bunch of your hazers.
Somebody's exposed to swinging.
He said somebody is explosive.
Yeah, because he's black.
I said somebody, Bro, don't ever put
words in my mouth and we'll he the black.
I didn't do anything but wow,
he's explosive. I didn't say that.
That was a stereotype of Mexicans.
When you're watching two
guys fight like this,
when you're watching two fight like this,
there's so
tense.
You know these guys are like,
when you have a bunch of bad
blood between two guys like you,
you can almost like see it in how like
wound up and pulled back. They are.
They also don't have a lot of
experience though either Joe.
Like it's only homeboys second fight.
She's kept up,
they cut the shit out of his back.
Yup. Does that work? Brian? What is it?
What's going on? On my personally, don't
believe it was on my knee. That worked.
How did it work? What did it do it I
had all like this bad blood in there.
That wasn't a bad circulating and it
literally got it out. It was like dark.
The healer. That might be some bullshit.
I call it placebo. Wait a minute.
You mean it got it out? How
does it get it out? It leaped.
They poke holes in your name and
put the suction. It sucks. The, Oh,
they cite the stagnant blood.
Yo, look at this high back mount.
He's getting a little sloppy there. You
just go a little too wild. Yeah, but he's,
he's attacking [inaudible]. We just
barely missed that. Left to her.
You can't lose guys.
He's getting loose jacked.
They are both six fellow you see on
the beach, uh, shed the black fellow,
the Brazilian. They both look like
beach boys. A couple of peach,
couple of beach bullies. I was talking
about the Brazilian character though.
He looks like some dude coming out of
the water with a speedo on for Dior.
Super uncomfortable about being
on the beach with my shirt off.
I go and run my Keto ass away.
I don't think he's a kid.
I just think he's a nice side light kick.
Great kick bamboo shit.
Bomb Boucher is those John Joan legs.
These things are dangerous. He's very,
very stiff for this upper [inaudible].
We just get head kicked.
He throws back shots and he's getting it.
Bamboos it looks a little tired guys.
Yeah. We're only two minutes in. Right?
That's being all tight and wound up.
I mean these guys got to catch their
second wind and I see him pacing moving
like at like nothing smooth.
It's all fucking moving.
A lot of looking to spin
from him a couple of times.
Both Guy Bam. Bamboozles
Hey Glenn, I think he's
going to lose when he throws it's big.
It's just waits for a shot. Yep. He's not
fucking around. He throws big shit. Yeah.
It's whether or not he
can sustain this style.
Dominick Cruz,
he was like,
he keeps switching stances.
Oh, tag. Yeah. But I mean he's,
he's obviously not as fluid as Donald. We
know what that, that uh, he looked at us,
glanced on heat though.
They're both drawn. He,
these guys are two dudes who don't
really like each other. Oh, okay. Oh boy.
Keeps looking at the blog or just
as crazy as I can't tell. Oh,
he's getting hurt while shit now.
Yeah.
Let's go board,
cheat and go and get bamboozled.
That's kind of smart.
Oh Gosh.
It was worried about the bodies when
we have a body now with the punches.
Each stroke I shot his first fight he got,
he's like Roberto Duran,
Duran Duran and Dominick Cruz.
No, no, no, no, no, no. I'm
talking about now the Brazilian.
Oh God. God. God.
God. Fight. Oh my God. The dread. Okay.
Chance presenter. Rans boxing.
It's like some of the best ever.
God knows the body shots
and that's who you are.
Cesar Chavez right there.
I couldn't drop that mark on his,
the inside of his, neither on,
on a Buddhist Sheena's knee and that's
how I rolled the yard. But I seen that.
I don't think that's
the right way to say it.
Well when chewing it like you're
in France or something, but
he didn't fuck. Yeah, I don't think books.
Can you come and take your Brazilian
accent for just a little while?
He's going to wild for me. You
know, but I'm going to try now.
That guy's going to go look at,
whoa. Oh, oh. Control the posture.
Posture Yourself. No, that guys,
because I was in France
because I was in Jamaica
then I was in France,
but I'm from Brazil.
Control position. Come on,
let him off posture. Very good
posture. While the first round guys,
he's having tried to walk
Mullin, Dude, he's wobbling.
He is fucking wobbling. Yeah,
and he pointed,
he came up to Jesus.
He's just going to help them to be this
dude's fucking oxygen to board she and
had just poured it on, man.
Are you going at this point?
You know what? The black dudes
and shape, yeah. Oh look.
You can be built and still have endurance.
I mean when Tim Kennedy with his at his
best, he was always built like a tank.
Never got tied to good
endurance. Yeah. Was He shredded?
Look at those Strikeforce days, both of
them shred city, but it's a fine line.
It's a fine line.
Like you get too much mass and not enough
conditioning and you work too much on
explosion in the fight and
not enough on technique.
Not Enough on pacing yourself.
He's got a giant,
she'll look at the Anthony Joshua.
He's shred shredded city,
240 pounds to 40 and and came back,
you know,
got draw lines almost and then came
back a track and the next round he got,
he dropped Klitschko and
then Klitschko dropped.
That's when he dropped Klitschko
twice in the final round.
Upper cuts were caused by the way, I think
it was a controversial stoppage. Boy,
that guy's built. Holy Shit.
Or Chino. It's the shoulders
stacked. Yeah, he is
man. Yeah, we'll just,
we'll just toss it up. Just go ahead and
let's definitely, I got amazing. Know.
That's what I'm saying.
That's all minutes.
Cause you know that golden snitches
sniffing around these two like go fucking,
he's young and he's got that mesomorphic
structure. It doesn't look out of place.
The hard place to hide. I know he
doesn't look like no one would be
facetious.
I don't know what I'm saying.
I'm not accusing me
double front shot anybody.
[inaudible] tour on the car tonight. We're
going to find out what the fuck is up.
What is he going to look like?
He tore it gets Nate Marquardt.
Both of them have dabbled
in iron man boulder. Yeah,
I'm going to make a deal.
They got to say, listen,
I'm going to let my sister be for me.
He just kicked dropout bombs. Now
it's going to be bad. Real bad.
Eddie, what was that club? Not really
tired and I didn't see the fight,
but how did it go aboard?
Chino put gets us. Eddie.
What was that MMA fight that you posted
on your Instagram or someone was gone
for the heel hook be trippin.
Oh Shit.
What was that MMA fight you post on your
Instagram today where someone was going
for the heel hook.
That was earlier today.
I was in the and the other dude is beating
the shit out of him while he's gone
for the healer within the minute. Ran
Out. Who won that fight? Matthew Lopez,
the guy on top, the guy that's
throwing bombs, Brazilian,
I forget the Brazilians name.
So the Brazilian was a cat that
was going for the heel hook, Tim.
That was a battle. Yeah, I put them
right on 55th tough. And he had,
when he had the, he had it, he
had it, but he held on and uh,
Matthew Lopez used to dealing
with heel hooks all the time.
Great Wrestler and oppressive defense.
Oh Man. Because he got the death's door.
You got to death's door a couple of times.
Yeah.
Real good defect but damn hammer fist
from hell. And that's the danger.
And go to the leg locks and they work.
They weren't,
but some of the times you're going to
get smashed. Jamie's got to play it.
Look it up there.
We get up there on the left.
I mean this is like his clothes he got
goddamn he'll hook is you're going to get
this dude's jacket on it and Yanking
on it and homeboy Matthew Lopez a bad
motherfucker. Cause he was in pain
here for sure. And he survived.
Look at this thing. Top Kid,
man. Oh yeah, right here.
They shouldn't allow a head kicks with
the fuck. Fuck. You should be able to.
It said,
why could you kick someone in the head
standing up and you can't kick someone to
head on the ground? It makes zero
sense. It's a viable move as spelling.
If you want to say to the guy standing up,
can't soccer kick the guy in the head
or stopped him in the head? Okay.
We can argue that because the cage,
because he can't go, I can't go anywhere,
but you can't argue that if
they're in that position,
the guy's going for a heel hook.
They're both on the ground.
You should absolutely be able to kick
just like you could accidentally elbow to
the head. You get punched in the head.
Yeah. Why can't you kick to that?
It makes zero sense. Zero upkick
should be legal now you're percent,
you're on your back.
Might be too hard.
It's too hard.
It's too
hard.
You can hit a guy with a wheel cake,
but you can't up kick them when you're
on your back and he's trying to close in
on you. Fuck that. You should be able
to go crazy. You should be able to,
with the guys on his knees, you should
be able to kick them to knees. One knee,
you should be able to kick the shit out
of him if you're on your back and I was
in Singapore and I hung
out with shots tree.
The guy who owns evolve any owns one of
scene or the guy who owns evolve owns
one FC as well. Yeah, one championship,
and I swear I've been doing,
I've been to a thousand UFC investors.
I never been to an event like
this. Really? Dude, hey bro,
you won championship as far
as production goes and ha,
fuck. Really doing English Clemente
high level English commentary for them,
it's the most incredible,
it's like month,
like this VIP section was just the
way it was all set up. Let's just,
let's just spend, there's no
budget. It was incredible.
Every fighter,
every finder that came out had
its own music video and own show.
They really go off.
I'm promoting the each individual fighter.
Each guy came out and he had his own
music video, his own song cut up.
Who's the big stars were there
besides his ass to star over there.
Ask them is a huge stuff dude,
that guy has some of this.
She's my way.
So that's
the reason I bring it up.
Joe Is I was talking with them and
I asked you a fucking goat cheese.
I said he was going from close going
back and forth on the rules like it cause
they allowed soccer kicks initially.
You see Brandon, very soccer kid.
Eventually he said we
got to pull them out.
You know there was a couple really exactly
know,
but it's his decision.
He doesn't have a commission.
He could do whatever he wants.
So to him it's up to him
and he decided to pull the,
the soccer kicks but out we and all kicks
on the ground and I said he included
up kicks and he goes,
well technically yes,
but he thought about it for a
second or maybe he allowed him,
maybe I'm a little confused
but as to what he said.
But he agreed at the end of the
conversation that upkick should be legal.
I mean you're on your back and
you allow a wheel commission,
you 100% should be able to
upkick at anytime with the
guard says one knee on the
ground to knees to the ground. No knees
on the ground to gray on your back.
You should be able to
get back to your feet.
It's a viable technique
and the guy shouldn't be so
confident that he can close
the distance.
Okay.
The only reason he is so confident that
he can close the distance and get get
ahold of you is because you can't kick
up kick them when you have one knee down.
Right.
It's a bullshit strategy.
What's it bolsters strategy based
on a bullshit safety. So Eddie,
there's no commission out there.
Now he's got everyone going sizzler
and he calls him crazy. But I,
like I said,
I've never been to a show like that.
I mean damn all the way you sold me Bro.
Do you guys think this one dude shot tree?
He's the man that gentlemen.
It's like he just wants the best show.
He's uh,
he's half Thai, half Japanese. Who a is.
Does the commentary for
English does rich Franklin,
rich Franklin just moved there to work
for him. I said they pay some rich,
rich Franklin.
Ben Aspirin wants to move there and his
shots was just move to Singapore and
worked for one FC. Holy Shit. He's done
buddy. But great thinking about retiring,
asking us, thinking about us, thinking
about our time never gets to the UFC.
That's such a fucking shame.
Yeah, that guy's an animal, man.
I can't see you and
beat our jam right now.
Do you guys think that you should job,
do you think it should be illegal to be,
if you're inside control Geneva head
hundred percent really when you're on your
hand, and we should be able to, don't
be in that position. Right? If you,
if you know,
if you guy can get you inside control,
you should be fucking
scrambling like a wild cat.
And if you're not scrambling like a
wildcat, it means you're compromised.
And if you're compromised,
they means you either got too tired or
you got to hurt and that guy should be
able to capitalize a need of
the head when you're down.
The only time it's a problem in my
eyes is when you can't move your head.
That's why pride was superior in that
respect because they had those ropes so
you can go on to the ropes and avoid
soccer kicks. You could avoid stomps,
you could avoid knees.
The only argument against soccer kicks
and stomps and knees to the head is the
fucking cage. Getting your head pressed
up against the cage and getting stuck.
In my opinion,
that makes it a problem because you can't,
the guy can't get out
of the way of a strike,
so then the artificial boundaries of
the cage becomes a weapon. It becomes,
obviously you can strategize
to get the fuck away from it.
Don't let it happen to you. If it does
happen to you, it's very dangerous.
It makes fights more exciting because
there's more opportunities for chaos,
but you're going to shortened careers.
I have a different point of view on it
in that I don't think that when you don't
have knees to the head,
we in San position are when your hands
are on the ground or for example,
soccer kicks. I don't think it
makes, if you added those things,
I would do think of a do two things.
It would not make the sport more exciting,
but it would make it more brutal and
it would probably shortened careers.
So in my opinion, I, it's brutal
enough and has enough technique to,
I know, but to not allow certain like, but
things, so I think more brood. I, yeah,
I've kicked her different story and I
was thinking that he's trying to rip your
knee off and you can kick them like from
that position. I think that's the luck.
Yeah,
you could break somebody's allowed brains
if they got their head cut caught in a
bad spot and you actually stomp on it
100% can you imagine just Brock Lesnar?
Cool. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well listen man,
I didn't match exactly.
Also asking him, I asked him about, I go,
what if a fighter wants to wear
spat like or irrational anyway,
rash guard. And whose decision is that?
It goes, my decision. I go, so Kiddo.
I mean women were rash guards all
the time. It's never a problem in a,
in an MMA fight. It's never like what
do we do with the wounds? Rash guards,
we can't have them fight topless.
What are we going to do?
It just like you just swear
rash guard. No, but no big
deal. There shouldn't be uh,
uh, you know, a rule prohibiting fighters,
male fighters from wearing
rash guards in my opinion.
I mean it's not a big deal for women.
Why, you know, and he, he agreed,
he said he would let anybody wearing
anything cause you want to wear a geek and
one FC. You can wear a geek. You can work
at Kido pants if you want. In one FC.
I think you should be able to wear jeans.
And I think you should tell him no,
no gloves and gloves. If you can
need something in the head, elbows,
someone in the face, you can kick them
in the head with your fucking Shin.
My Shin is so much less
vulnerable than my hand.
No, but take away the paddle and the
knuckles. If you're going to have padding,
we should have padding on the shins.
We should have padding on the knuckles.
We should have absolute patting on the
heel cause the heels the most dangerous
in my opinion because I
could wheel kick something.
You could hit something really hard. It
doesn't really hurt your heel. Right?
But you get,
you punch someone in the head.
You have a really good chance if you
hit the forehead of breaking your hand.
I've never heard of a guy we'll kick
and grind ahead and hurting his foot.
I mean, I've hurt my foot to
the point where I was limping,
but I didn't hurt my foot. I never broke
it. It was like our we, but that was our,
we office someone's fucking
head. Right. You know like the,
the idea that you could pat up your
knuckles, you don't pat of your heel.
It's crazy. Your heels. A goddamn hammer.
I mean t, what's that dude's name?
There's a dude who just
fought in Bellator recently.
I'm going to pull this up because I
told this kid I would give him props,
but he'd knocked out somebody
with an ax kick. I saw that as my
background. Might be the
only time ever. Hey Joe.
It was after the main card
though, right? Like he was the,
he was on either before the card
or after the main car doors do.
So there'll be the main event and then
it's over TV and then we'll have guys
fight after. Yeah, like one or two
guys fight after. Okay, homeboy.
His name is Eric Davis.
Yeah,
Alfie are Davis.
Alfie Art Davis and he
acts kicked Kudzu acts.
He acts kicked a dude and and which sweat
this dome. Oh wait a minute. Go again.
Back it up again. Here we go.
Watch this. Oh no way. Come on.
Told you someone was going to do that
eventually. Cause that's happened.
I've seen that happen.
And [inaudible] Hook kick.
That's what I want to see if that, I don't
think Derrick, the black beast Louis.
No, that wasn't, that one wasn't, that
wasn't Bella. I, but I do just for answer.
But Derrick Lewis got knocked out by
Sean Jordan with a front leg hook kick.
Get the fuck out of that. Sean
Jordan, who's 250 pounds, 260
shithouse British bulldog but
can do backflips whack. Yeah.
Shall I draw back Lsu Hook kick front
leg bill Wallace. That's awesome.
Style Shin Shun join was a freak. He's
freak athlete. Here it is. Here it is.
Oh, what? Yeah, that was actually,
it looks like you brought it
from the back of that. Yeah.
And it looked like it was almost a
sidekick. Right? Let's say it again. Boom.
It's definitely a hook now. You're
right. I'll show it in slow motion.
You see the hooking? It could
be a shitty sidekick. Yes.
In cause I mean look at it.
No,
it's a straight up hook kick from karate.
Karate back. Boom. I mean, that's amazing.
It Derek's like why even though you
don't train for that as a heavyweight,
he's a crazy athlete. Football
background, football. Yet.
We're supposed to go to the NFL,
flip 250 pounds full backflip. Ooh,
five should I be built like a,
like just a troll,
like the thing from a fantastic guy.
They said he was going to
UCLA as a fullback or whenever
he was and he was that
big and he was dunking a basketball.
He's just standing there and just jumping
in and going. I was like, what the fuck?
Shut Sean. Jordan was supposed to go to
the NFL, but he got caught with some uh,
Brazilian supplements crossing the
border and then it fell. It was like,
we're good. Go. We're all set.
Yeah. Oopsies he's a freak though.
You got to send those in the mail side
named Mark Courses. Same. We get a bugs.
You get over stuffed animal animal teddy
bears to a sick care of your buddies
up. Nothing to lose. Put up their ass.
Come on. What are you doing tomorrow?
Listen, you still have student
loans. It's time to become a Buell
time to become a mule.
I hope Nate wins.
If like if one day in the future you
have 100% transparency and you get to see
all the crimes that are committed all
across the one how many times per day or
dudes coming across the border with
drugs up there ass. Oh my God, my God,
I got him a mass right now. I've been
offered a few. What's the number though?
A hundred a day and more
play more thousand a day.
A couple of dudes do that day
got caught going through Kennedy,
I think with coke taped
all over their body
to the bullet up randomly.
Touchdown man.
That's a big risk to plus the,
but I think dogs can only smell one thing.
And they usually use them for bombs.
No, because with a drug
dogs though, they can smell,
you know he'll have with drug dogs,
but don't,
that motherfucker did a good job.
That's very smart and good job on your
ass. You know what he should've done?
He should've got it shaped like one of
those Batman suits where all the muscles
are like he's intentionally
do it. Yeah. Yeah.
But he's in deep shit. Guy's going
to jail. He's going to give, Ooh,
look at that vagina. Cain. Cocaine.
Pretty giant. A giant. Wow.
That's looks like it's a butterball.
That pitch has a big pussy. Yes. Well,
I feel sick now.
Once you've had a few kids,
I guess you could probably get a Turkey
in there. It's cool to us play that makes
them feel safe. Six kids, half
a pound. That's impressive.
Christ and her veggies.
Think about what Gil Kane,
if you pack it tight,
isn't it like a rock?
Half a pound might only
be like a fist big tube,
but might be giving this gal
more credit than she deserves.
Look at the size of that fucking thing
and the thing is almost always the saying
this. Tell me, Oh perspective. Now it's
almost as thick as my cock. If you look,
it could be a pill. Oh, look at veto.
Coming out for the last time. Maybe.
What if veto like,
I mean he's only got one more
fight left in his contract.
He thought this was the last fight
and then he was going to leave. Yeah,
you fucked up. He didn't count.
Right? Not a good sign. And then, uh,
one of the other things you said
recently that was crazy, he's like,
he wants to make UFC bigger than Uber
and everyone was like, hey homie,
Uber is crashing right now.
If you understand like the
amount of punishment that
Uber's taking online. Huge.
$300 million million dollar
loss. First quarter. Yeah.
All sorts of controversies
attached to Uber. Like what?
Oh, that's a good question.
The CFO to their final button, a bunch
of people that's a little bit troubles,
but they'll come back. Uber. Yeah.
But it's just a weird time. Uber,
the actual idea and the service didn't
work out or is it, was it just bad?
That's a good question. I
don't know what, you know,
I looked at it peripherally like I
saw like, oh, Uber's in trouble again.
Uber's of the new president
has said some shit that they,
they've lost a lot of money and that
helps lift. Yeah. That Lyft is, um,
the new version. Right. That's
what a lot of people use.
It's like the 99 cent store for Uber.
It's kind of funny.
I know uses Uber and it's awesome.
You ever fucking fucked up Uber
Pool and accident and people share.
There's like six people in the car damage.
You were trying to save money.
I'm like, I just did on accident cause
it automatically goes to it and I'm like,
what the fuck? I'll just fucking
wait other people's houses.
I got an Uber for my friend and uh, he
was gonna, he was going into my podcast.
So I'm watching him from his house and
I'm watching the car doing all these
fucking terms like flexible Victorians.
Jesus Christ,
you'll be towards crazy pucks flexible.
He's just doing standing splits. Oh yeah.
He's a fucking athlete, man. Oh
my God. One of the greats, man.
If this guy never had a
chemical controversy, you know
what I mean? If we, if we,
we had a frozen time machine from 1997
on and you've got it all dialed in.
He bought one of the
grace of all teachers,
the one that he's one of the
ones that got caught. Yes.
That's what I think for sure.
But he's also an interesting
case Vittorias in that, you know,
he's had like these spectacular victories
and then also some really brutal
defeats and his spectacular victories
are very rare because he's a sprinter.
He attacks you in sprints at you,
which a lot of people don't do.
Like v Torches Dean's you a little peek
a little bit and then he sprints back in
the day. It has. He ever doesn't
work these days. Guys know it, right?
I don't know. See, didn't the
TRT, it absolutely worked,
but he's also 40 right, so it's like every
bit of man. Like what is [inaudible]?
There's a,
there's something to be said for the
strategy of your heard a guy in MMA,
you have little gloves on
and he just fucking swarm
him. But you're going all in,
all chips in.
Has He ever been down?
Has He ever been down and come
back? That's a question. Yes.
When Anthony Rumble Johnson, you got
fucked up. I rumble Johnson in Brazil,
rumbled,
didn't even make one 85 rumble was way
over one 85 this was back when rumble
went up from one 70 to one 85 didn't
even make one 85 put a beaten on veto and
then ran out again. Ah, ah.
Yeah. Who else choked rumble out
to people? Forget about, ah, yeah.
Rich Clemente motherfucker school.
How about that?
Rich [inaudible] who used to fight at
55 that was, that was that young, dumb,
crazy.
You know what?
It was 100% he cut too much
weight and he couldn't sustain it.
When we did warrior,
he was kind of,
he was walking around at two 35 to
35 I remember asking him, I said,
you're a giant. And I said, you're
going to suck down on one 70 I go,
how are you gonna do? And he goes, I'll
make it. And he did such a mad idea, man.
I think that's one of the
reasons why five pounds,
he had this bad feeling about MMA
in the first place. Yeah. You know,
when he says he doesn't like
fighting him and make Jesus Christ,
you're one of the top two fucking
light heavy weights on the planet.
Top two or three. I mean,
rumbled beat him. I mean a DC
beat him the last time. Oh,
there's these two spectrums.
Brown's time. Awesome. Vito Belfort,
four 50 54544503452 couple of
veterans than sink earlier.
And for those who don't know,
Brendan Schaub density trained with Nate
Marquardt back in the day and you said
you never saw him lose around. Never,
never. And you know realize right it.
And they trained together too
for the rumble Johnson camp.
We all flew out there to
help you so that you know,
they know each other a little bit
and they're also Jesus' brothers.
If you don't know that you're there,
they're also brothers and we're going
to see who Jesus likes the most.
And this fight when Nate is Wilkin
quite thick. Yes, he is strong as shit.
Nate is a freak athlete, man.
Yep. Super Freak. He's awesome.
If I since he was 17 it's almost like
Nate just just missed the time periods.
You know, like if Nate in his prime,
whoa. Nate is coming strong here man.
He looks very confident. He
looks very fast too, man.
Beautiful trip.
Vito Vito Vitorin his back is not good.
This is not good except against Jon Jones
against Jon Jones. Jon was slacking,
left his arm out there and [inaudible]
pulled off the rare armbar off his back
and hopped on his arm.
That fight too much.
Sorry.
No,
you look at veto with the elbow from
the bottom was actually a very strong
people asleep on h Jitsu too.
He's a legit black moon widget and
he's a fucking strong dude too.
And if you could hold Vito here and beat
him up and he's doing aggressive shit
too, like you sticking, it's
fucking to see old Nate man.
It's such a smart move by Nate.
Cause veto or like you said,
he's only dangerous than the first.
Really the first round.
After that he tailors off so bad. So
for Nate, this and the sec around,
I bet he tico. Wow. Especially
the Vituro of today.
That's what I'm saying. His,
his testosterone levels.
He says her super depleted and
he's got a real problem and yeah,
I mean it's a weird argument, right?
I mean, why are they depleted?
You're only 40 you don't stand them up.
It's a dominant position.
That's terrible. Fuck you. It's Brazil,
Bro. We want to see people bang. Yeah,
but that's terrible. They're doing it
because it's Brazil. Yeah, that's right.
I mean mean mean. I don't know
how many warnings he gave him. Oh,
we're not listening to the commentary.
Well,
he's trying to move vittores tighten them
up. We know. It looks like to me here,
it looks like Nate is like
super confident coming in here.
This is a like a Nate who
knows his opponent and feels
real good that about his
chances. He looks confident. He
doesn't like tentative at all.
Mad Skinny.
He knows he's Vito or just
physically does not look that good.
He told us just waiting for that one.
Like,
look at the look at the excess body weight
around his waist and his legs look of
consistent 40 though gap,
but
fires away that I'm 50 and I don't
have that. And by the way he's,
his endocrine system is probably a
little bit, you know, compromise.
Well that's what I'm saying. Yeah,
100% yeah. He also, Oh shit. Get away.
I just dripped. Oh this way. You can't
caught that one to the body to go rough.
But I mean he caught it on his elbows.
Fucking scroll. Front leg side,
kick to the leg. I love that kick
and it's got some treks kids.
I love that people are doing that now.
That's a legit technique.
You know the people think
that it's damaging to the
name. You think it's dirty.
What about heel hooks? Look, it's a
good technique. If you can kick the leg,
that's a good way to kick the leg.
And what are we doing here?
You could blow a guy's knee out with a,
with a regular tie kick.
I can't believe that's even a debate.
I can't believe it is.
He was thinking sturdy. The Jackson
camp really wants who started it.
They do it brilliantly.
We other really did.
And they also do with that elliptical
kick, which are uh, that. Um,
what's it not elliptical care. What am
I working on? The word oblique kick.
That's a beautiful kick.
That's a beautiful kit because it's wheat
that fucking flying knees
down to my leftover there.
Whatever your name is. It's Brennan
shot. Oh, sorry. Brennan shop.
You fought in UFC door does not look good
here. I get excited. My test, my test,
my test starts spiking.
Guys, when I watch fights.
What about when you hear engines?
They said no, no. It goes down.
If you let your testosterone to spike and
no disrespect, bring up vittores wife.
Good God. Yeah. God Mighty. They'll
Brazilians will, how to make a wall.
You're going to talk about my standup and
coming to my show? No, I dunno. I Dunno.
It's in Irvine.
June 8th ninth and 10th and good Jack,
you brought that up name Nate gave him
a finger like Yep, you got me there.
The one finger, not the bad
thing. Right. Got It. Oh,
nice. Couple of couple of front foot leg
kicks, guys cook. He said, no you didn't.
Oh Geez, Nate. The thing is where does,
where did these guys go after this?
You know what I'm saying?
Like the winner that heaven,
one fc to Ralph was there.
Vitro is going to show up when the party
Vito is going to dress like a soundbite
fighter with shoes on combat. Sambo.
I love it. They just went like,
let's take this but not this.
Let's take the shoes but not the
wrestling singlet. Let's go with it.
But not the pants. Okay. So
we'll go with head forgot.
Beat tours at Tristar.
No, for Rasa. Hobby for hostels.
That's racist for us. Her
Robbie. Oh damn is is damn good.
Brian Cowen. I'm sorry if I'm shooting
to the microphone. I got you. I got your,
your wine. They get your cheese. Got
here. We're going into their next,
she made it free to leave it. I'm already
going. No, no, no. You're, you're,
you're in California. You still in
California at Eddie. Philip, Philip.
Finish off California. Do. I Dunno. I'm
working on it, but uh, not for comedy.
Just for hanging out and went to
the Amalfi coast. Changed Year.
I had a great time. It felt
real good. What the fuck is
my copy to? Really, sorry.
Oh sorry.
There's something about the way people
live in other countries where they're
super relaxed and they re but
let me tell you something man.
I had a really interesting
conversation with a cab driver.
Cab driver was driving us
around who takes cabs? I do.
We were in a place and they had a
cab and you know we've got a cap.
They have cabs there.
Oh word here around round tube.
One of the interesting thing the guy said,
he goes, ah, he goes, I want my children
to grow up in America. And I said, why?
And he goes, because he goes, man, he
goes, there's opportunity. He goes here,
there's not much you can do. He was
a smart dude and he was a cab driver.
And so we started having this like kind
of cool conversation cause he spoke,
I believe he spoke four languages. He
said maybe they're very smart business B.
This was in Amalfi coast. Where's
that? It's in Italy. It's a,
there's a place called
Ravello and rubella.
Rubella or Velo I think is rubella. But
anyway, it's beautiful. Gorgeous. I mean,
it's just pretty, the beaches
are nice. The oceans gorgeous.
And the people are just awesome people.
Just so nice and friendly and
interesting. But they, they,
they don't have a lot of opportunity
as far as like, um, careers.
More the simple life
according to this guy. I mean,
I mean if you live there and don't,
don't, yeah, according to this,
but the cab driver was very educated.
He was a smart fucking dude.
We got super lucky. We went there
and we went to Rome and, uh,
we went to Rome. We had
a really good, a guy
named Mark Court. Ladies and gentlemen
don't owe any fucking hand. Dude. He
looks great. He looks fucking great
to be, be this wine to earthy, bro.
A beautiful wine. It's super earthy.
He's that good. Do you? It's a lot
too earthy from alcohol.
Real number. Cut vetoed.
Just tagged him with a left upper cut.
Why don't shake his head
kick five feet tour cuts.
Oh, Shit. Uh, time up Nate Dogg.
Yes. No mate, Nate's coming back.
This is a fight guys. Holy Shit. What a
fight right hand by Nate dog won a fight.
Man. Is this an argument
for no testing? I yes it is.
Fuck yes it is and I'm
currently makes sense.
Neither of these guys are good testing in
there. I'm kidding. They're testing. I'm,
yeah, but, but still I,
I would like to see guys who need
a little help fight for longer.
It's called the master's division.
Nate Marquardt was one of the only guys
that's ever been pulled from the car.
Is that real? How dare you? That's
horrible. Dare you put that back up.
How dare you put that bag of sweet.
You look dog that.
That's a beautiful look. It's incredible.
I got to get on testosterone right now.
I think that's more than test. All right,
well I'm to do whatever he's doing.
It's post endocrin crash
two on the righthand side,
like a healthy looking dude
who's 40 years old. Right?
It can be pretty jammed and apparently
the birds compromise looks terrible then.
Yeah. What's compromise? His
endocrine systems compromised.
But Nate is one of the only guys that
Sarah had been pulled off of a card
because he was on legal TRT and he shit
was so high. They was, hey, hey, hey.
No.
Do supposed to be fighting Rick story
to keep him and beat him to buy tomatoes
defense. I know exact cost went down.
The doctor Nate didn't remember. Sure.
The shot's himself. The doctor didn't,
and he's like, no, you're fine.
And it was like, you sure? And he goes
yes. And gave him the shot. Yeah. Yeah.
He went to the doctor. Feel good. It's
looking good. It's looking good man.
He looks real good. She got here,
he had a red beard. Look at that.
It's switching up. Looking at us
in touch. Nate Dogg. Yeah, natives.
He switched it up good. And he's
also turning that left leg in. Good.
Like to get rid of the check.
That kick. He's sharp, man.
It's a better rest though. She'd
take two more take downs. Well,
he got that one in the first round.
I got stood up.
He might be a little bit
hesitant now. You might say, oh,
he's looking very good. We're
on the champ. Oh, look at
that cohort rule plan here.
Wow. Oh ha ha. What it means. Fuck.
It means balls. I mean, Dick Hands-up
Gracie used to always say that.
He'd always be like, boy,
Huh? It's like fuck. It's like
when you say fuck, you know,
you can say fuck or you can say shit.
It's the same thing.
Some of his bikes like [inaudible] boy do.
Do you remember when Nate Dogg Fuck
Woodley and strike force for the belt and
straight like Congress ministry that
Nate Marquardt that finish was one of the
finest. Oh, look at that big cut on
vitro. Oh, we won't. The head kick.
No body. Nate, Nate, Nate, Nate.
Nate is no dope.
Always swinging shit.
Do Nate looks fucking fantastic.
He does. Yeah, he does not.
Since the CB Dalloway fighters,
he looked as good and that
was a one punch knockout.
He knocked him the crazy. Yeah,
but that was way back in the dead.
Super old school. Five Dude, I'm
calling it. If you knocked out Victoria,
let's bring an Anderson spider it again
home. I on your back, you imagine?
Yeah. He's got as good
as it looks here, dude.
If he looks as good as you looked here, I
just, man, I might have to go with Nate,
right? Oh, oh. Oh. How
about, but listen, Vito,
Vito, our poles for
this. How about Horace?
Trying to have it.
How about that?
Vittores going to sail off to
rise and just go Bain on us.
He's got one more fight,
but he's got one more fight
in his country. Oh, Dang dumb.
They both think these guys are there.
A couple of Ding dings. Ooh. Hey Man.
[inaudible] bonds called it shit.
I call this Dang [inaudible] heard his
voice mails to a side piece he called,
but it was a girl with Barry bonds. I know
what you need. You need some Dang Dang.
And it was just like, it didn't help them
at all. It was just like a horrible day.
Yeah, exactly. Me Too.
Don't fucking Barry Bonds for being great,
even though it took steroids and
likes girls hit me that night.
Fucking baseballs. I want
them on steroids. Exactly.
Whatever it is.
Nice.
Demised baseball.
No UPC kicks in baseball,
no feet towards, got a big cup.
A lot of scar tissue on that man.
I'm sure it's pretty easy to open them
up. Look at some highlights. Boom.
Clipped him with a right hook.
Nate with the high kick to,
do you remember the story of veto a
sister dying man when they took her for
ransom, but there's that upper cut.
Yeah, it was horrible. Horrible man.
Took it for ransom and they
killed her and do the right buyer.
Brazil don't put ground. No. That's
the worst thing I can imagine.
One of the guys working for the UFC. It
got held at gunpoint this weekend. Really?
Yeah. What happened? Nothing to give them
their money was just a production guy.
Well God damn,
here we go.
Brazil is beautiful. It's dangerous as
shit. Well, you know Chicago's dangerous.
Two men go to the wrong place in the
afternoon on the south side. Yeah,
just as dangerous and a lot
of places it's just, you know,
you can have crime everywhere. You know
where it's not dangerous. Australia,
Australia is beautiful. I'm headed there
tomorrow. I love it. I love Australia.
Nervous as shit about it.
Why are you nervous, Sydney?
I don't know why you let us necessarily
traveling, man. I don't travel.
Might as well be Americans. They'd be
like, they're like, you know what I say?
Canadians are 20% less douche bags
then a American the way nicer.
Same thing with Australia. They're like
Canadians with a cooler accent. Wow.
I'm sold. Did the shit. I lived
there. I could live there.
It's not even in America.
They drive on the left side of the
road. Never been there. I'd live there.
How dare you not go there? I know what
he's been offered. Your 50 go there.
I've been offered. I just haven't
gone. I love it too busy training.
I went to melt. Wow. Okay. I
went to Melbourne last year,
maybe year and a half ago.
She do shows out there. Joe Now. Fucking
loved it. Yeah. You do chose. Yeah.
Did a couple shows out there
that love you, Brendan.
Brendan's going to be there and he's
sold out a bunch of theaters. Yeah,
they'll love you for sure.
They're great people and by the way,
big as United States.
Same amount of people as la.
We're going to dig that entire kind of
chose as big as the United States. Yup.
Cause he can take you a start with Alaska.
I did nothing in the middle.
Right. It's like on the skirt.
The middle kills you.
Everything in the Middle East.
Your ass eat your ass and then in
the ocean and shark city. Yeah,
the ocean sharks city.
The water around the ocean is
crocodile city and you get deep inside.
You got snake city and spider city.
They have brown snakes.
They kill you instantly.
Tiger snakes,
a bunch of spiders to kill you
instantly enjoying the water to cool off
crocodiles boxes, box,
jellyfish box jumps.
They fucked.
Some guy sent me a picture of a
saltwater croc passing a great white.
Oh Jesus Christ. I think it was
photoshopped. It might not be.
Let's say it helped you live
in the Australian doctor
sent me that. Sorry guys.
Doctors sometimes are not
savvy with the Internet.
They have student loans to think
about it and they doctor photographs.
He's not a professional.
Made my mark car with a fucking dude
inside kick these, these. This is red.
How do you call this fight?
Right? He needs to finish him.
These guys are bruised up
because Gilbert fuck around.
Sel Brasil is looking great.
We'll vittores a legend so he's already
up to rounds. You know what men?
Nate looks super strong in this fight.
It does.
It's back is looking swollen like
by super strong technique again.
That's got to his defense looking
good too. Well, he looks like health.
Not Tired at all. Yeah,
he looks healthy. Right?
I think also a big thing for Nate was
going up to one 85 improved this CIM.
It improved his, his vitality. Yeah.
I just think being at one 70 he was
so depleted. Who's a big s seven oh,
he's huge. He's so big. Walk around
at 12 feet is so strong, man.
Oh Man. He just clipped detour. Did
he catch him with that left hook?
Did it graze them grace
because he grades them.
This is an interesting fight,
man,
because I think both of these guys
kind of at the end of their UFC rope,
right? Arguably. Oh, tagged them.
Boom Pole on the back. Nine.
You both look right, but
they're both, they're both like,
if you didn't know that and you saw this
well veto, you tell kind of by his body,
you'd be like, something's
going on. He's a legend though.
So he put up with the body fat. Yeah.
Well it's not just the body fat.
It's like there's a looseness to him
all. We, I kicked him with the left.
He a bunch of muscle down there to so
much more meat. It's all gone. So meeting,
but it's technique is still really good.
Have such a freak.
Oh Jesus Christ caught that on
the, on the elbow. People Forget.
Vitro is one of the best athletes
that ever coming the octagon.
Come on on the steroid.
Shit out. Guidance Stroll.
We'll kick at all until he fights. Luke
Rockhold throws one in missing sometimes.
Another one at Kaos him. Oh boy. Nate
got hurt there. You got tagged. Well,
he went looking for that takedown. Looking
at what I call an educated jab guys.
Oh, but that left high kick is strong
and they keeps moving to is right. Yeah.
You could block that all day, dude.
This shit is going to fuck your arms.
I'll tell you what's weird is, was
Tristar with GSP for ab. Oh Shit.
Dang done with that head kick.
So I'm wondering for us really helped
Vittori with his game plan for sure.
You know,
some fucking trailer or something about,
I can't believe what you're saying.
I'm just kidding. I'll let you for us,
look at that right writer when
they show Nate's right side, like,
look how red his fucking arm is.
He's also Pale as fuck. I know,
but that's why you can see the impact.
Like when you have a super white boy,
you get to see like where
he's been getting scratched
up in the white boy. Yeah.
How long was the veto with for, for
us just this case. Just what does it,
all the redness all over Nate's arm
has been known to jump around campus.
That's kind of his thing. Hmm. Well
sort of, but I mean not that much.
I mean a lot of guys have jumped around
more than him slapping me from named
Mark White Ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
Oh Damn. That's tough in Brasil. They're
probably going to be a great fight.
Great fight. One round one
and two. That's great. Fine.
Not balls deep and cheese and half a
glass of wine, but from my perspective,
one and two, as long as more cheese,
I'm time traveling from that weed.
Goddamn la speed.
We'd would the,
what is I say it was bamboo
leaves or something like that.
They wrap these blunts with, with
bamboo now Sam's panda style. Yeah,
some quality bear style.
That's a beautiful installers.
Don't fuck with bamboo.
Oh man, they didn't have that wrap. That's
all right. Come on. You guys stopped,
was it? No, no, not at all. The other day.
No, I don't got shit on it. Yeah. Yeah.
I know what you're talking about on
second angel dust or something real.
The real interesting thing,
if you're going to go blunt,
you really should go Charlie Murphy style,
which is where you take a Swisher sweets,
classic the weed and you put it inside,
take the tobacco out and so then you're
getting the harshness of the tobacco and
you get that weird tobacco
buzz from the outside.
They had that weird nicotine buzz. I like
it. Nicotine buzz every now and then,
man. I've smoked cigarettes before.
I've done, yeah, what a great times,
but I've smoked a couple of cigarettes
before going on stage before. I like,
this was a great fight, man. What's up
Donald Serone. Oh yeah, I ate some dip.
Oh fuck that. I swallowed some Dick.
He took cigarettes. Every now and then.
I say Nate's got it. But you should
win two to one. It's personal,
but do they have the same split decisions?
Let's see what we got here
for this contest.
Oh, all three feet tall.
Piece of shit. Brazil.
I'll fuck you. Oh, come
on. Put his hands on this.
Damn. It's Brazil. That's
you got to figure you up.
You're just like Glen Brazilian
lose around I guess. I Dunno.
Good fight though. Those are terrible
jersey. I say the feet, right? Definitely.
That last round to one. So you
thought vitro one, two? No, no,
no, no. Hell No. Nate one, one and two,
and then he, then Vito in the third round.
Veto anything again.
I paid a shitload of provolone.
I've had some wine and a lot to watch
some good moments of the fight by
[inaudible] and I thought I saw
a few more good moments by Nate,
but I was in no means judging
the fight by no means profit.
Brian Stan with a pink tie. Confident
gentlemen. It's not a big deal. You know,
even a fee.
Those first two,
he did lose the first round kind of
big right cause he got taken down.
I'm struck,
it was all about Brazil.
Is Brazil going with the new rules? They
do it the fuck didn't want, but did they,
did they have the new rules? Like as
far as judging and everything like that?
I don't think so.
Texted classy man.
The Texas doesn't, uh,
doesn't accept those rules.
Brazil is the wild west and New York.
That's it. Everyone else you're,
they're false shoot with,
well New York has just juvenile New York.
They're just morons.
What it is is they just don't
have a lot of experience.
New York state is only
had MMA for a year or so,
so they're just going
through growing pains.
I feel like that's what's going on with
New York. It's just, when I say juvenile,
I mean like they're childish.
They just start having a had a while,
but the mistakes they're making, I mean
you're talking to in extreme mistakes,
but who made that mistake was Dan Merkel,
Yada Dan Margiela Yada is a
super experienced referee.
The guy who made the
mistake in the Mercury Yada,
it was a merger led to her. I thought it
was herb dean. Which one was Mark Liata?
There's what? Which one was
the Musashi fight? Was that
herb? Dino. Herb Dean. Okay.
Then the mercury out of fight was,
there was another woman was in New York.
Was it Weidman? Weidman watch one
was Weidman was saucy. I thought.
I thought it was her. Her Dean
was born. That was that one,
but there was one with a, there was one
with American Liana recently. Either way,
the point being both Margiela Yada and
herb dean are excellent refs and no shit
goes wrong. Man. Her been
fucking up lately though.
He's my favorite fucking up.
A lot of people have been saying that.
I'm not going with that. Well I'm,
it's just, I mean you're going
to fuck up every now and then.
You're going to fuck
you really can't breath.
I fuck up and submission only
and I fuck up every now and then.
I've done maybe two or three big fuckers.
Fucking done 1,000,005.
You're alive man.
How can you not fuck
up that kind of speed?
And sometimes I think I'm saying like
[inaudible] but I'm really saying Nate
like I'll fuck it.
I'll have it in my head.
Cause crossed because
what I'm trying to just,
I'm trying to pay attention and I'm
all trying to talk at the same. No,
it's not the weed. No, because
I'm doing, here's his back.
I don't do the UFC high ever.
Ever. I did like two high ever.
I didn't like it like when they
back in the day, back in the day,
like 2002 or something like that. But, um,
I don't do them high cause I don't wanna
I don't want to ever have the urge to
talk about some shit fight related
because that's what this is. Like,
this is the whole, this fight,
this fight companion podcast shows the
whole reason why I should never do.
We'd what does that, when you
watch it, that's more Gelada there.
That's the Weidman was saucy
fine. Okay. So I was right.
So Weidman versus Musashi
was Dan burglary, Yada. Um,
the other one that was similar,
there was another one that was similar.
That was herb dean.
That was a recent funding fowl as well.
Who,
what was the fight people on line
right now? Oh no, it's dirty.
Alvarez and pouring.
Yes. Thank you very much.
My fucking beautiful,
beautiful,
beautiful [inaudible] top on that.
So that's, that's a perfect example.
I respect super.
You got to give me a list of top five
best referees on the planet Earth,
Dan Merkel, Yada and herb dean or bolt
on that list. And they both made errors,
although he's number one, he's the
gold standards. And by the way,
not like this. Oh sure he did. But
Marillo Bustamante versus um, oh,
in 19 [inaudible] fucked up.
He tapped him.
Marillo tapped him and then they restarted
the fight and did it again. Look,
he's the gold standard because of his
experience. And that was a mistake.
It was just experienced and it was
a loss though. Currently though,
he hasn't fucked up like he's the best.
I feel like big John's the best,
but I'm feeling by far,
you know,
here's another one that doesn't get enough
credit because he went to the pokey,
Josh Rosenthal,
he's Josh Joshua sand outstanding.
He's out. He's out. He's out.
He's out. But he never got yes,
snitched on him.
He, I'm a brown belt in Jujitsu. I
think it might be black by now, but uh,
what's he doing now?
He's refereeing and getting,
did some keying in the cages and shit.
But here's what the referee X. Excellent,
excellent, excellent,
excellent. [inaudible] he's
one of my favorites. Yeah.
And also like super like
out of the picture, like you
don't even know he's there.
So his homeboy with the, the
Yosemite Sam Mustache, Mike Tran,
Swan Beltran Bell trends in my top
10 in the world to stop three from,
he's one of the smartest.
I've deal with a lot of people
in the industry over the years.
He's one of the smartest dudes I've
ever met and Mike is fucking great human
being held. Is he so nice? I'll try him.
Nicest guy that got to be nice about
tomato mustache like that. By the way,
you knew he was a cop and you're
a Mongol. He was like, Huh?
He was like an undercover,
uh, I think an undercover,
like special detective thing that might
wanna look at your phone off. Yeah.
I don't know. Mike Beltrani was, hey,
was an undercover like, oh, I
shouldn't say that. If he's not sure,
he will double down. I, no, no, actually,
maybe I shouldn't be talking about it
and it's too late. You Fuck, sorry.
Just ratted him out. Now you're
going to die by talking about it.
What you should do is not, I didn't
know that, but I'm just going to look.
I got to look at, you
know, he's writing a book.
I think that didn't give
me super skeptical Hipaa
wise because he's writing a
book. I think he's going
to write a book about his,
is someone going to true hall of fame?
He's writing a book that he was not
just in the UFC hall of fame. He,
this is soccer. Rob would go into
the hall of fame, commentate on,
I come in straight from yoga to do these
fucking UFC and it looks so fucked up.
I look greasy. I have red marks
on your face and head, hot yoga.
I slept for the next two days, but
I just looked at myself, I'm like,
they can only usually a couple seconds
of video of me. I looked at her lineup,
we get done for, I love Sakuraba. Oh Man.
Soccer. I grew up in the UFC hall of fame.
The greatest. That's what they're
doing. I think that's what this is.
And then they health,
he'd wear shirts that said water on him.
He fought in the UFC and also
because the UFC owns pride,
it's a legit um,
oh.
So we learned pride guys in 100% they
should obey Dorin fade or wanting to lay
cro cop bar.
But [inaudible] has got that issue.
He landed a turning sidekick on Vito
or they put them down on the ground,
Euler, Euler didn't tap and
then they stopped the fight
anyway and he's like, no,
no, no, no. I didn't tap.
What's so cool about broken?
So Gracie's arm Anton has a
picture of that cancels on,
but with a boiler boiler it just
didn't tap and the boiler was like,
I'm fine man. Like yeah, I'm
getting my arm chewed up.
But like for a boiler that proved
to be the case in your fight Eddie,
because when you're that grappling
matches that you fucked his leg up.
I remember watching that
from the sidelines and I was
like, this shit is so over.
The last guy he just took it.
He just let his knee get mangled
or is he that flexible dude,
there's no way he can be that flexible.
He's just tough as shit.
He dealt with it.
He dealt with getting his knee torn apart.
Hence a wash on the paper.
Hence roof. Curious to tap.
Yeah, they want some swatches.
He just walked as his own fucking
arm break. He will not tap.
I'm eating this cheese like a Monday.
Can Jake at afraid? Isn't that crazy?
Yeah. Shot. Trey wants me to
do a tone in did a supermatch.
Shachi wants me to have one that can
Sakharova. Did you see, did you do it?
Are you going to do it? But how's
your back dude? I don't know man.
My back is not 100% yet. How's
your back for a hundred thou? What?
They offered you like serious cheese.
We haven't even.
How's your back for hunkered
down on a wheel of challenge?
I want you to shut the fuck up.
I'm negotiating for them and we're
not starting at a hundred. No.
You at least the hunting.
Some cheese bro and all this cheap.
We're talking about check or is it
coming up and talking about dollars?
A couple of things.
Shackles still haven't recovered
from my back surgery one too.
I'm trying to find out if I'm, I need,
I might need surgery on my shoulder.
I'm not sure I've been doing that.
Hang in therapy. I don't know man.
Hang right now.
Not yet.
But based on those videos
that I'm watching about the
hanging that uh, you know,
if you have any kind of tears, if
you hang, eventually it'll fix it up.
That's what I'm hearing is that wrong?
Hinged mints.
What it is is one of the things that
happens with people with shoulder injuries
is you get a lot of pain from impingements
means your mobility is impaired
because he get tears and damage and then
your shoulder sort of like gets scar
tissue to never, it never increases its
mobility or never regained his mobility.
And one of the best ways
to regain your mobility,
get on a chin up bar and fucking hang.
Just hang.
And I hang every day, every day.
It's one of the main things I do.
There's two main things. How long
do you do it for? Two minutes.
But I'll just start out with 30 seconds.
Just loosen up,
get my hands loose now
and then I'll let it go.
And then sometimes I'll go into a minute
and a half and sometimes they going to
two minutes. But I take
my iPhone, I put it on,
I hit the stopwatch and then I hang.
And you're one of the reasons why I
did it because when we, first of all,
because it's really good
for your shoulders, but two,
because we did fear factor and we had
men and women hanging and the women,
all one the men couldn't
hang glider cause him. Yes,
because the men are too heavy and they
couldn't hold their weight up because if
you're a man, even if you have
stronger hands, is stronger muscles,
the amount more that you weigh like
against 130 pound woman, you, you know,
most guys are weak in that regard.
And most primates,
that's one of the things
about the shoulder,
like our shoulders came from primates.
So the premise behind this
hanging is that some of the,
the lack of mobility and impingements
and problems that we have at our shoulder
joint is simply from a lack of your
shoulder articulating correctly and
stretching out like and,
and doing sozo doing range of
motion things like I do a lot of um,
Kettlebell a shield casts with,
I'm not a Kettlebell, but a club.
I do these shield casts, which are
really big. So these big movements,
you got to wield the sword. And another
thing I saw, wonder woman bro Strong. Yes.
I think I do that I really recommend
is bottoms up kettle bells.
Will you put the kettle
bell upside down and you're,
you're working on some serious stability.
This is only 40 pounds, but not man.
Very difficult to do like that. I
don't know. That's pretty impressive.
Let me see Brian try that. Well, I
could do it now. It's 70. I want to,
I started out,
okay,
can I bring you to Italy for a
second and pull your little wine?
Then I'll then I'll show you how that
shoulder was fucking, it was that,
that shoulder. I had to have
a, I had a stem cell shots.
Shots already sold as Jackson.
The show that I'm pulling back,
I shot maybe 80 arrows today
with the 86 can we put this up?
He was smoking my before. Well, no,
he did it ladies and gentlemen. It's
hard to balance. Well that's really good.
It's really good for stroke,
shoulder stability. They will,
let's just start off light.
If anybody's doing it and I recommend
no more than five repetitions,
I believe in that for weightlifting.
I believe in no,
no more than five repetitions and
I think you're really cardio. Yeah.
Your cardio and your endurance
should be done doing other things.
Either skill work like martial arts,
whether it's Jujitsu or
kickboxing or strength and
conditioning work like running
and shit like that.
Fucking 12 reps send them an email.
I don't think so.
Sun lift off
your 250 pounds. No, no. Pretty
Shock. Reminds House, you look gross
sir. Shop reps with 600 pound
revenue. Not done. Not done.
He reps with 600 pounds.
That impresses me.
Those fuck movements. Oh God,
yes. That's the best for him.
She kept 600 pound barbell. That's
right. Sitting there doing this shit.
So even big goes like this motherfucker
will let me have a ahead of time now
he's, he's, they're strong
than the shops. Strong.
You've been lifting since you were
at, but fourth grade, fifth grade.
It's got some 10 Sam, I had a shoulder
question. Oh, what was it? Sorry.
Just take that goddamn
fight. Okay. I like this.
Yeah.
Well the thing about the bottoms up kettle
bells is they say you should be able
to do 90% of what you can do.
Normally.
Most people can't like 99% can't,
but they say if you have a real stable
joint, what's going to hold you back?
It's not strength. It's a
stabilizing muscles, the
stabilizer stabilizing muscles,
the ones that oftentimes cause
issues with your range of motion.
And with using it in terms
of functional strength,
like I'm using it for martial
arts are fusing it for, you know,
anything where you would be using like
I guess what I would even think sports,
like throwing things. I mean I would
think that shoulders to abilities,
like super important.
I remember when I was going to ask you,
when you say no more than five
reps, do you mean uh, use the, uh,
the amount of weight where you fail
five rounds? No, no, no, just regular.
I've been following this Pavel
Satsu Lien regimen and he created,
he's like the godfather of kettle
bells in the United States.
He's the guy that came over from Russia.
He's,
he's got a ton of books
out and videos and,
and his belief is that strength is a
skill and that you should never do a skill
when you're tired. And so
the idea, and I'm, I'm,
if I'm paraphrasing and fucking
this up please, I apologize.
But the principle behind it I know of
and the principle is that like say if you
can lift something and
you get to like seven,
eight reps and you get to the age rep,
keep
going,
keep going.
It's like she'd never do that because you
get the strength from doing the amount
of repetitions. Like say if you
do five reps, you can get to,
if you could do 10 to five
but then wait a long time,
wait like 10 minutes and then
comes took five, wait another,
wait another 10 minutes, then do another
follow. People would beg to differ. Right?
You're right, you're right. A lot
of people, a lot of people would,
but I guarantee you if
you had a cobble on,
you should listen to Pavle
on Tim Ferriss's podcast.
Do a little bit every day.
It's kind, Kinda like you do
a yes, exactly. You should
make sure that you can,
you can do that too.
But I'm telling you,
one of the good things about this is
you have people that get injured less
because your, your muscles are
never working like full fatigued.
They're never working
to the point of failure,
but you're still lifting heavy weight,
but you're lifting.
Say if you could lift something and you
could do 10 repetitions, don't do 10,
do five, do five, put it down
and take a big long break.
But it's not endurance.
It's like you do a scene.
I'll be doing the same number of reps.
The problem is it takes longer.
Like you would need to be at the gym
for an hour and a half versus 40 minutes
and it doesn't burn to death.
I had a guy who
there's some benefits to it.
I think that as best as to,
I don't think just doing
that all the time. Those,
the answer maybe I would love to
talk to have you sit down with,
you should have him on your show,
man. The guys in California, poppy,
he's a wizard and he speaks
perfect English wiz or did
they change your sheets?
Three of us should do it because you're
a fan. He's a fest. We should do it.
I'll do it. I'll do what you
guys do it. I want to list,
could even have them in here. Um, one of
the things that he, that guy brought to,
um, to the United States is
not just the kettle bell,
but also like some serious
fucking bodyweight exercises.
And then like some movements
that now have become,
have become like really standard.
Like I'm Brian counts pour me from
and where are you going to Italy?
We need to learn now. Now we're in, in
late 2008. I want you to take your time.
Like I need a food food.
He's going to like my Italy hit.
This is via Ben until while I do, but
what I was going to say is that, um, uh,
Turkish getup, which is a big one of
this, it's huge. Turkish get up is so big.
There's Pavel, the dude's a stud, by
the way. I always wear sweat pants. Hey,
bring shab up doing a Turkish get
up with one 45 please bring him up.
Isn't that ridiculous? It was with a bar,
which is even more than that. 200 pounds.
Then you do two 25,
225 pound Turkey,
one arm techniques. Awful.
Yes. The technique is off.
It's not that awful begging for a blown
disk, but that's still super impressed.
Who? 25 225 they're strong
in the shop. I told you,
hold on, I'm going to get you.
I'm going to fruit you up.
You want to go California, you want
to stay in California? Look at this.
How much weight is,
is that that right there is one 45
that's one 55 one 55 look at him.
He's a fucking beast.
And he did it with two 25 is ridiculous.
That is ridiculous. The technique shit
though. You bet it doesn't matter man.
But the point is that you have that kind
of core power that you can get up from
your feet.
And how applicable is that to grappling?
So one of the most applicable, like
when terms of like functional strength,
Turkish get up is one of
these most applicable because
if you could fucking lie
on your back and press something and
then sit up with that fucker overhead.
That was my move.
If you remember like with ruling
as soon as the arm would pass them.
So I can try to just,
oh so strong if you or to Turkish get up.
Yeah. Strong Turkish get man is
like one of the most for Jujitsu,
especially one of the
most applicable movements.
Kaja Dahlia Versus Carolina Kayvon cause
she said Jackson, good fucking fights.
Got Somebody to change camps.
The Jack set some traps on her and
she's got that dude, not Greg Jackson,
who's the old guy. That's her
main coach. Oh fuck. Oh my God.
The forgotten man in New Mexico.
Oh my God.
I can't remember. Cologic Adelia he was
part of the [inaudible] winkies lack.
Yes. He's really close with Keith
Carradine and Rashad. Oh my God.
Anytime the wall and he's
like a New Mexico [inaudible]
a legend. He's a cop. No,
not Steven Seagal. You
son of a bitch. A cop.
Latrelle nope. Latrelle yeah, but
not something like this that Steve,
it's something Latrelle Tim. No,
no, thank God. I remembered that.
The trail something Lou trail,
right?
She's just a door guy.
Liens on the case you want say Calphalon.
You want to go ahead and live with me?
She is
very strong. Brennan Shot, proven
CTE. Can Be overcome. Thanks.
The output from the Alpha
brain and some copy gas,
10% off cheese. That article shop about
that drew Michael Finley had about CCT.
No, it's really good. He wrote on
the player's Tribune. Oh really?
He did a bunch of like Ben's. We'll work
with it. It's I'll, I'll link it on here.
Please do. Jamie. Jamie,
we want it. You want it?
You want to come to Italy if you have
Anatole with me or do you want to let me
finish this California.
Oh Shit. California.
Claudia is by far the best 150 pound
girl in the world. Nut named Yolanda.
She's so fucking good. She's
pretty Badass. She's very,
she's trapped and she looks like a little
Brazilian pimpled and they're like,
well, this cute one that's
six PAC sun. She's gangster.
She wants to do Ebi too, depending on how
this fight ends. Like if she comes out.
Yeah, she's, she's an athlete.
She's gangster. Oh, Mario.
The hearts as you do that hard thing
because he really loves emojis,
but he can't bring one into the octagon
with him. We did quality a good daily.
I relaxed his fuck. That's Carolina
[inaudible]. Whatever her name is.
I meant that's what I meant. Claude
Jack Kadeja. I know. Now I know that.
I just love, I love Polen. I love
her. I think she's gorgeous. She's,
let's see if she gets the rub right.
She went five hard rounds,
but Yolana let's see. What's a passion
comes back. Oh, clean, right hand.
The polls have been through the worst.
They're history. They're like, fuck up.
I octagon. I went to World War
One and two mother fuckers.
They don't fuck around eating munitions
with your breakfast. They suck.
Holds there a plan in both wars. I saw one
vitamins. Nothing you saw wonder woman.
I grew up Patty Jenkins by the way.
Number one.
I think it's going to be the
biggest growth. Any Romans,
I'm proud of her good fucking movie.
I heard it's really good. It's good.
We like superhero movies
and I love superhero movies.
It's a good fucking look.
When you make a superhero movie,
you're confined to make a movie about a
superhero and the good guys to win and
you know that going in.
She dealt with all that and she did it.
She did it on her own terms and it's
about us. It's about Patty Jenkins,
the dude I don't want to spoil or
almost spoiled toilet wonder woman,
wonder woman, Patty Jenkins. I
enjoyed the fuck's that radar.
You don't want to hear as good.
It's on iTunes now is that mutual life
that Ryan Reynolds movie people keep
telling me that will see that movie dope.
Chris Pine is hilarious and wonder
woman though, right? I love that guy.
You know what I did today?
I get a bad father of the year word.
I let my nine year old watched
the original alien shit.
Nope, she'll you think it was cheesy.
She's okay. She's okay. She's like,
it's not real daddy. If it was a
real thing, I'd be scared of it,
but I'm not scared to appoint kid. I
love it. Kids, man, they have iPads.
They get online when you're not looking
at it, can see all kinds of shit,
fucks things up and he knows that
shit next to that. They know things.
Might've daughter used the word, the name
asshole today and I had to scold her,
oh, you should have led with that guy's
an asshole. I was like, hey, write you.
She said you're right, but don't
tell anybody. Right. But um,
the thing about the alien
movie is that there's no CGI.
It's all like a mummy can't, it's no,
it's a dude in a suit. So it looks real.
It's fuck, that movie was done so
well. Really? Scott was a wizard.
They did everything in that dark.
Everything was like real sneaky.
You only saw the alien for
like quick bursts of it.
It's just like American Werewolf in London
with John Landis. You see it and like,
Ooh, sat control. Did
you see the new alien?
I did not see it yet.
Having a hard time getting people to go.
No one in my household's capable and my,
my wife said I could let her
watch the original alien on TV,
but I can't take her to the movies
to see the new alien. So yeah,
wait til it comes down to man. The
wife makes the rules. The flux.
We were trying to keep all the time,
but we were trying to keep it too.
We didn't want him, you know, we keep
farming. My wife died. Falling was a bet.
So we were, we were trying
to keep it to, don't toot.
Oh No, not her. She's got her
eight dash dammit. Whew.
That was a big mistake. Fuck.
That's a huge,
huge victory for her.
Oh my God. Going to get that powerful New
Mexico in the house. Here's the thing,
here's the question. Joe, do you give
heard the, the three against you on it?
Roads is supposed to be next though.
Oh Shit.
That was a crazy, ah, she snuck
it under. Go MMA math on that one.
Knows lost to Carolina.
Carolina just got murked Supermar I
was too relaxed my rails with you on.
It doesn't matter if you're relaxed or
if you look nervous. All that matters.
It's how your ground
game that does happen.
So you just like pretending
that everything's cool leaning
against the fence. That ain't
going to, that's not going to wait.
What was the mistake she made there?
Well, you know once it, so first of all,
it's physically a beast.
You're in the first round. No
one's tired. Yes. She turned
towards her. She gave her backup. That's
second grade bullied last yards short.
It is, man. It's panic
shit. You just like,
God want muscle my way back up to my
feet. But now she's like, I control it.
That's where it all ends. But she's,
she's controlling here, right?
She's got her and she's also,
if you her,
she's only got one Bush to go one go
two on one. She's still, she's fine.
And look at that second hook.
Once it was under the chin,
then she goes second hook.
That's deep. Oh yeah.
That's how she does an
undeniable choke right there.
That's like you go to sleep once that
stuff is the title shot ally. Thanks.
He dies. Well, I really want to see
rose because we've seen it. Sorry,
Rose Brazilian
girlfriend.
I would like to see her versus rows.
Let's get this started. I was chilling.
I would say,
oh my foot hurts or an enemy.
And you guys go to therapy
shortly into random me.
Like I'm good.
I'll just fuck your belt and
you ran it. He's like, yeah,
I never really wanted to fight one 45
in the first place going on 35 and that
girl arms like you know, let's see Ya.
This is her name. John Judge Jack Young
Jay. Got It. After two years,
I would say 80% of MMA fans know how to
say her name. Now she's getting famous.
I say he still calls her
champion Brian Stann.
He calls her you want to champion this
cause he can't pronounce it one more time.
You're on jet check. Check. Done judge.
Like young Jamie. No, no, no.
Like why you went and they spell it out
for me phonetically when I still read it
for the Engencia when I have to.
I might be doing it wrong,
but when I have to read it,
uh,
for the Wayans it's like why
you and j a y and then check.
What was your first,
what is your last name?
Start with what's the
first to Jay Jay. Jay, Jay,
Jay, Jay, Jay's CSP. Come on Jj.
What they call her. I know most
people, Young John. Bad idea though.
She's the only Jay Jay other than Jon
Jones. There's one too much confusion,
but the problem is your ingestion sounds
like Jay y. That's like one of them.
Them tight. Once the Thai guy
start flooding into MMA. Oh,
you thought you had it hard with
the Polish people tie guys come in.
They got like 35 letters and the
sea for quite some way. Well, why?
We're waiting for the next fight comment.
You guys see what the fuck
tall guys are training.
You see what pollution going on,
right?
Did you see what lion fight did they put
this dude Leard Zilla do you know learns
La? I love his name already. He is a,
he's a multiple world champion.
He has 180 [inaudible] him in
there with a guy who had zero.
No to me.
Moy Tai debut fights leart,
Zillow and gets head kicked
into another fucking dementia.
Look up there. Look, do
watch this. Look at this.
But Watch. Watch the combination though.
Wash the combination. Do you hit it again,
Jamie? Oh, is it a Instagram wash?
This front kick to the body. Bang.
Kick. Insane. The other guys
in MMA fighter decent record,
he's got like a six and four
or something comparable.
There's a champions
training evolve right now.
Lured Zilla on earth.
Yeah.
He's got the best Zillow's real name to
relax our shit front kick to the body.
And then food round kick out of nowhere.
The fuck that guy fight him.
He was a fake leg kick to the head.
Fake front kick,
roundhouse kick or they
call question mark kick.
But what happened was a bunch
of people to lion fights. Uh,
this is to,
you know,
to their credit credit or in
the interest of full disclosure,
they had two people pull out that didn't
want to fight this guy. And I'm like,
fuck that. This guy was making his debut
so I fucking fight him. He's crazy.
If I was his manager, I said, listen to
me son. That wasn't an MMA fight though,
right? No, no. But it was a guy who
had a record in MMA that was like,
it wasn't good. It was, I mean, it
was a default. The record. Yeah.
He had some losses and he had some
wins, but he wasn't, he wasn't.
Habib never got that off.
And we're not talking about a guy who's
like an elite world class striker and
he's fighting. This guy learned Zillow.
Let me see. Oh, fucking assassin.
1000 bucks for that and a headache
for a year long headache
Nunez versus that is
come on top. Robert Wilson
car top to bottom Whitaker
and that fight. And he goes,
well, you never know. No, I'm so that's
the main fight. Now that Tj and um,
and Cody are out, you all wins.
And then he beats bear. You
know what the fuck you're talking about.
Robert Whitaker could
beat anybody in the world.
He might wait. Mike, you put the
speed. Everybody. Excuse me sir.
Excuse me gentlemen.
He's paid everybody who's,
he lost her jock gray got or
you got fucked in that fight.
He defeated in MMA thinking that right.
Thank you gentlemen.
I haven't said it from day one. World
two time world champion. Wow. Well,
you really picked an underdog brand,
but he is a gorilla when it comes to
wrestling turtle. It's ridiculous. Shred.
They look real. He's going to win the
world title at 40 years old. He might,
he might, or Robert, Robert Winter might
put those fucking kangaroo paws on.
Robert Whitaker's going to
take that fucking right hand
from Australia and knock
his ass. I'm going to need you to
calm down. You got on the train,
you've got this eighties in Saint
Jacques and arm, which I appreciate it.
And thanks from early 2000
whatever the new kids on the block,
it'll be new kids on the block. First
of all, I appreciate it. Thank you.
I admire your courage, your
fashion courtesy. Thank you.
I'm also outraged at the same time.
It's okay in the pot that you did.
You get it for free once he bought it.
We've got a new kid on the block, man.
He got out the new kids on the block
store. They're backed by the way. Okay,
so this is the main event. We're
at the main event already. Yeah,
it's nine o'clock dude. Oh, you
don't want to fight? We will.
We didn't miss it cause it was on the,
uh, the prelims. But a Sun Sal vs. Dot.
Miralis kid from a world
series of fighting. Oh, what
happened? The Sun's out.
Beat them real and I split decision.
Some people, yeah, we're up.
People think Mariah's one, but a
sense of beat him. Wow. Interesting.
Marlon Moraes in my opinion,
was the best hundred 35 pounder in the
world outside of the UFC world series of
fighting though. Well,
no, but he's really elite.
If you look at his skill set and the
way he moves and who he's training with,
Ken, retrain, Mark Henry, Frankie Edgar,
Edson Barboza. I mean that's his camp.
Everyone is so high on a man.
I always,
I'm high on to the hype machine til
you get to the EOC man to beat people.
You're right. But I mean it's his
first fight in the UFC and the son's
first fight.
But it should be though you're,
you haven't lost since 2000
like for some shit. True.
But if you are the UFC, if you're, if the
UFC, someone says, look Brendan Schaub,
we're tired of running this.
Take care of this.
Wouldn't you want to build them up?
I would want to build up Marlin.
I wouldn't want to,
I would let everybody know how to get
my highlight reel when yeah, me too.
Cause his striking so elite, he was not
bitches out and they need a new content.
Exactly.
You put him in there with a guy who's,
he's a monster, a monster and
he's not that exciting. Yeah.
You put them in there with a good
hundred 35 pounder who tests them.
But you know what man,
that's how guys lose.
And that's why you find out who they are.
I mean that's what happened.
Sergio Pettis, right fought Alex Cause
Sarah's they through right to the wolves.
And because Sarah's chokes him
out and you realize like, okay,
like you got some shit to learn kid.
Yeah you're fucking talented. But Hey,
try to frank kegger a year and
biggest thing, uh, you know,
uh,
who do you have in this fight?
Because you tend to be
scientific about your pick. Man.
This one's so tough to pick cause
it Joe say it's so tough to,
it's fucking Josie all though. But I
just for yourselves Max Holloway's time,
I feel like his box and he's bigger Max.
Holloway's very smart and he's very,
very like fluid with his movements.
He moves in and out really good.
He stays in the outside, he'd do
anything. Here's the question,
but how's he going to deal with
all those leg kicks? Big Question.
And it goes to the ground.
People forget all those up fucking
world champion on the ground.
Although built cold, he beat [inaudible]
in a regular Jiu Jitsu match.
Everyone forgets about his grappling.
He's such a beast of a striker.
Ways that can be trouble for Holloway
cause just wants to fucking strike.
And I think a lot of it depends
on like where is Aldo at mentally.
Well he just kept off the Frankie
Edgar fight. He looked fantastic.
But before that was talking
about retirement remarry,
retired, true play soccer.
That might've been an asshole is
all in though Max. Always all in.
What else is in trout max?
Max Hallway in a Steve Bay is these guys,
they just run their camps like
he's not in that some super camera.
Why is he holding a British flag up when
he's from Hawaii? You son of a bitch.
That's the Hawaiian you. Oh my God.
Even know if he had been in Hawaii.
Can Can we meet? Meet with Mike for that.
You never been to Hawaii? [inaudible]
Shit. Never. Never. Australia and
never who? I had never sat down there.
Fuck everywhere.
I've been to all those email.
When you talk all this shit about
traveling to come to my world,
I will probably try to top track
one tune in tomorrow night. Yeah.
Don't talk travel when Henry Rollins
don't feel like a townie. God,
that guy's been around, hasn't it?
You know what he does every year?
Picks a spot on the map. It go like
that. Bali causes far as travel agent.
What can we were going on?
Bali.
He just flies out to Bali by himself
with a laptop and a camera pair of
underwear.
Toothbrush just lives there.
That's good denture boy already do the
same thing back. Ari went super deep.
You wouldn't even deeper. He went for four
months. Ours like, I'll show you much.
I'll shoot over the wrong.
If you're looking for why fight and
your destination, you're not trapped.
Ari Shaffir stressing the fuck
your Wifi. Fuck your phone.
If you really want to travel, really
can't. You've travel with a funk.
I travel all the time and I like,
I'd rather stay home.
Once you travel to a thousand cities,
you realize it's an illusion.
Everyone's trying to
travel to where I live.
People are coming from Australia and I'm
going to fucking Tahiti, French brother.
You're walking through the airport
and you see the destination,
the be all end all, some dude's
feet on a fucking bad ass beach.
That's, that's the the goal.
And then when you get there,
you realize, wait a
minute, that cutting off,
they framed off like the people trying
to sell you a fucking a crocodile
unloading [inaudible].
Dot. That's right. Dot.
I went to Thailand. I go,
I'm going to go to the desert of fucking
island on Thailand, and everyone said,
yeah, you can. I go where they go,
you need to fucking take a cap.
Three hours jumped in a cab, three hours
I'm gone. And then we finally get to go,
what are the islands? Oh, you want to go
to the island? Yeah. Yeah. I'm thinking,
I don't give a fuck how much it
costs. It's just go. It's cheaper.
If you go on a big ferry to this island
or you could take a speed boat to go
fucking speed boat and let's go, boom. I'm
video taping. Everybody wants to speak.
I want to go on this fucking
ion that I see at the,
I see him all the time. I don't give a
fuck. I'm getting book money and Shit.
I don't give a shit. Fuck
Thailand nonstop. I go,
I'm going to go on a fucking
island. You get there, boom,
and there's 200 other people there
and there's like snack bars and shit.
The secret is
the island.
There was a Tracy,
it was a trick. I spend all
day finding this fucking I did.
I was on a speed boat thinking they were
going to take me to this island and he
remembered I was going to eat alone.
Beat boy Jason from England.
The mole Deeves got to go to the mall.
Deeves Jesus Christ.
Hey, did you see Josie Aldo in
Brazil? He has a restaurant.
It's just American burgers in Brazil.
Really just cheeseburger.
It's called famous
burgers that's ridiculous.
Famous and he sells cheeseburgers. Hey
man, is that cultural appropriation?
Because a bunch of chicks
got roundly Hartland.
These girls got ran out of
Portland because they were
white and they were making
burritos. Yeah, because the United
States is called the appropriation.
That's how you get better at and I don't
want a white girl making my burrito.
Brian's about to go Fox News on us here.
I was a Korea,
Korea.
They got a Mexican joint curry.
They play fucking Mexican
music making the Burritos,
make it Mexican food.
If we ever do a fight companion that's
like in Europe or something like that.
It's on the weekend.
I got to take you guys to a real
legit Mexican joint down the street.
Do they have like, yeah.
Okay, here's a super legit,
you order for us is a super legit Mexican
joint down the street where like every,
all the, all the TV is in
Spanish. All the music is Mexican.
The beep of Bailey speaking
you could barely order,
you'll be the only you and I in him will
be the only English speaking people in
the room. It's fucking tremendous. Totally
eat. So like girls Muto on the weekend.
Ooh, I can't stand the legit minuto. Hey,
why did these guys all have Bahrainian
on what's going on over here?
Super Skeptical eyes guys.
What's going on with the Guardian Angels?
That makes shit like I was raised
with the Mexican like no it wasn't.
We didn't go. We went to
Mcdonald's. When my mom, we're like,
we're going to all those ram
going to Mexican restaurants.
Yeah. Yeah. It's two d.
He looks tremendous.
Like physically, dude,
he looks as good as he's ever loved her.
That looks like,
although when he fought Chad Mendez,
when it first, what are you saying?
It looks fantastic.
It looks like he's motivated.
I'm not saying shit about steroids bro.
It looks like a cheeseburger.
Then say Shit Eddie. I didn't say
shit but just by asking what he meant,
he looks tremendous.
That was cute.
I will squeeze sale is very strict I
think for the good, for a guy like Aldo.
Well who's been the champion
besides Conor McGregor?
There's only been one ever
145 pound champion in the UFC.
That's that guy you're looking at
right now. So with a guy like that,
I think many times it's
a battle of motivation.
Yeah. I mean he's so dominant and
he's been in the game for so long.
And here's the crazy shit. He's only 30,
unbelievable all the years that Joe's,
although has been dominating
and you think about it,
I mean there's the guy who beat Frankie
Edgar right first time and then beats
them again the second time. Maybe even
cleaner, maybe even better. Right?
Think about all the people that if I do
the Chad Mendez fight the second fight,
a war, uh, the more common
toma, but that was also when he was
having a hard time making that weight.
That was when we did that press conference
the day before the fight and it was
the day of the weigh ins and he could
barely be on the ds because he was so
weakened by the weight cut cause he
hadn't weighed in yet. I think all go.
I mean the crazy thing is he's always
going to be judged by that Conor McGregor
fight she's picked up, which it's kind
of crazy. I don't judge him for that.
Fuck that. But it is what it is, but
you kind of have to higher profile.
Finer showed that a guy
can come in at both guys.
Talented is Connor can come in and first
of all fuck with his head with Connor.
Absolutely did get inside of his head,
create a lot of stress for me and a
lot of pressure forcing a rush and then
Conor just relaxes fuck slides out of
the way and drops that left hand bomb on
them. Here's a question for
you guys. He solved the puzzle.
What happens if Holly comes there and
merge some of the first round with his
striking, then it's going to really
taint his legacy. Here's the,
was never fought any really, really good
striker set for Conner. Uh, Holloway.
Thinking more.
What happens if Aldo kicks the shit out
of his legs and has him hobbling and
Roblin really early and
winds up stopping him?
Do you have another Conor
fight and we just go up to 55.
Does he go up to 50 shit cause he wants
to see Dana had Dana goes just to get
him to commit to this. I have to have
a serious talk with Mike Connors.
Never going to fight. You got to
move on. Like that's never happening.
It's so crazy.
Connor makeup fucking hunter.
Do gillion dollars fighting Floyd and
then come back and take on a fight against
Joseph.
You're right,
but is a guy that just fought
Eddie Alvarez a year ago. Right.
And you've got to remember the result
of what happens with Mayweather is huge
like Mayweather. But let's just say
that on the off chance that may,
whether just just, just merch, some it
just doesn't get hit. Not even once.
And after that Connor's going
to come back with a fury. Yeah.
He's gonna come back with the theory
to the UFC and say, fuck boxing.
I'm going to come back
and this is my sport.
If he makes it to a decision, he
looks tough. He won't be tainted.
It all depends on what happens.
If he loses super played with,
he's going to come back
to the UFC with a fury.
But if he goes to the decision,
like you were saying,
it's a win for him and it's close right
at the top time when for us, no he not.
Even if it's,
there's no way Connor would
ever let Floyd survive.
But hold on it.
If they had a five round MMA fight,
let's all agree Floyd Mayweather would
never fucking survived despite a chance
in hell. They would need, there's there's,
there's a chance, there's a very, very,
very,
very not unlike chance that he reimbursed.
You have to bring you guys to the
attention of the great no choice.
We have to watch this fight and give
it the respect it deserves and listen,
settle down. No, I won't settle
down because this is a very Cyril,
depends on what kind of take down
training yard take down defense training.
Floyd Mayweather.
Mayweather puts himself through the
delusional kind of training or the real
legit take down. It's good point.
That's a good point. Cause they go,
do they go for 50 74564505454
if you're sinking,
it's one of the best matches for the year.
If not the best feeling each other out.
How nervous are they built? Max Holloway
looks very smooth and relaxed. So does,
although everybody looks good.
No one's doing that.
Then I just want to see Holloway's
answer for those lake cake.
Well, the thing is Holloway's very
clever. He's not going to rush in man.
Like you see the way he fought,
Jeremy Stephens mean he adapts.
So we fought cub Swanson.
One of the more interesting things
about Holloway's because he talks,
you know he's like a cool Hawaiian kid.
Like people kind of sleep on that.
Like they think of Hawaiians is being
like fun loving like Surfing Party and
people. You don't just mean j pen.
Yeah, I know what I'm saying. I know,
but there's something about like the
way he talks almost something about,
it's almost like you'd think he's just
so nervous right now is BJ telling them
are coming back? Yes. You're still
fighting, fighting fucking homeboy.
Dennis Seaver and Dennis
was doing too much.
Bj can still have some awesome fights,
but Yahya was just not the right match up.
Hey, hey, this, although look like his
himself right now or is he look nervous?
Oh he looks perfect. Nothing's
happened right now. He's just moving.
See He is probably aware of that.
Max Holloway wants him to commit and
Max wants to counter. Max Is Taller,
longer fighter and he's also,
max is very good at not loading up.
If you ever watch max hallways fights,
he throws things very precise for the
most part me and he'll load up if he can,
if he can get away with it.
But he's like by attrition,
he's just very technical
with his striking.
He doesn't have a lot of super straight.
Yes, exactly. Straight punches.
He doesn't have a lot of fat and its
movements and because he's a long tall guy
that makes up for it means so much.
He's got long tall,
which is great and then he also
has like super efficient movement.
He's hard to hit. It's hard to hit. Yeah,
he's really hard to get like a clean
punch out. Super hard to hit any,
he's fucking smart. Max Holloway's
fight Iq is very high, super high,
and they crazy doesn't come from the super
camp either, but he just a holy book.
He clipped all the right there with
that left hook and he also knows how
dangerous all those leg kicks are.
So right now,
oh shit.
Oh
Shit.
Oh my gosh. They all know how
those are higher shit on fire.
Oh my God. Couple Lion. Oh
my God. She's see, forget,
forget how good.
Although
I remember when he hit Chad Mendez with
the Duchy with that left hook to the
body of that right leg kick and you
watch them do it and you go, oh Jesus.
Max Holloway weathered that storm.
Whether that fucker he did cheese,
his eyes are wide open chat.
Should we come back any now
right off the suspension? Yeah.
Do you know what his
suspension was for? No. Well,
no. It was for something that he
used for psoriasis or some shit.
They test the Shamira.
There's something in some psoriasis
medication that makes you piss hot new.
I sound like a fucking Alpha male
apologist right there. Don't I? Shit.
PDS. No, Brendon, no. Thrive.
Even though Chad Mendez could jump out
of a fucking five foot pool and he's only
five foot seven. He's, he's a, he
is a freak, super freak athlete.
But for real, that is what he said. And I
believe him. I cared my, he does have it.
I know he does it.
Have these like a lot of photos with
it where you could see it on his skin.
And I know that steroids are a
way that uh, the handle that shit,
but if you just put that on the thing,
you might be all right. G h our PS,
what it was before it came out of,
he had no idea what it was.
Man Does explained to them.
The test results came back.
They told me I tested positive. I was
like, I don't even know what that is.
Bunch of research sucks.
I love Chad.
It says Roy is used to
treat plaque psoriasis,
skin condition he's been
dealing with for years. Fuck.
So it seems legitimate Chad. Yeah, he's
fucking, you sought a relaxed. Yeah,
but his God do Max Hein got take it?
Yeah.
He called Max Holloway. Dung
them back. This is fucking,
Ooh. I'll tell you what does a huge speed
advantage on all those sites. Although,
so goddamn explosive. He's so
good at closing the gap, man.
Like you remember that Mendez knee, he
landed in their first fight. Oh my God.
Ooh.
I wrote, I'll never forget
calling the Uriah faber fight.
Got Uriah Faber fight was one of the
most horrific displays of leg kicks.
Worst thing in the world. Who
are, I said he wanted a faint.
He was trying not to faint from the pain.
That's what he said.
How tough is Uriah toughest? The toughest.
I didn't [inaudible] Hall of fame.
Never quit. Now Tie sky. We
broke both his hands against her.
Fucking Mike Brown kept fighting and kept
fighting. Nobody tougher than that guy,
but you don't get tougher.
Okay.
Did first round first he
documented the damage to his leg.
Oh my God. Oh, backs hall with the
math. That doesn't work on Josie.
What would it worked?
So there's something in psoriasis that
shows up in the head of the treatment for
psoriasis, something in the treatment
that shows up. Man, that'd be a good idea.
I had to get on some juice of,
hey listen, go get it dyke.
Go get a prescription for this stuff.
So
right away that was brilliant.
But I cured my psoriasis.
I have plaque psoriasis and I cured. I
don't know what happened, but I just,
you're sucking a lot. You could
do steroids sucking. Strange.
John's out 12 and then
no. And then I heard you were
sucking Dick stopped eating, uh,
taking a touching cow, dairy. And uh,
there's this book you ever read that book
called the plant paradox about lectins.
Really good book about psoriasis.
Yeah.
Well there certainly the bone psoriasis,
but if you had psoriasis like he did,
that's a reason to read it. Yeah.
It literally these recommended
no, no, it literally,
I get up my shades,
I get on my legs shorts.
So we all agree. We all agree
the Boldo one, that first round,
fuck yeah. Fuck yeah. Right? Yeah. That
book number 10, eight two. He looks good.
It looks good. Cool. Oh, fucking
sneaky. Left Hook to the body, man.
Although one of the best ever,
ever,
ever still that sneaky left
hook to the body is no joke.
And he follows it up with that right
leg kick a lot. And by the way,
he hasn't thrown any of them yet. I
know. Not One, no, he doesn't want to
one hobby. But that's the same thing
that happened with Frankie Edgar.
See a lot of people anticipate the idea
that all those going to try to take them
to get some serious fucking hands.
And when he knows he's not going to kick
you but you think he might keep you,
then it opens up his hand.
She has it too dude.
And His hands are no fucking joke because
he's so much faster. The Holloway,
the Tude, all those hands are like
lightning. He's, he's been talking lately.
I mean I would like to
find out how serious he is,
but he's been talking about lately
about possibly one day fighting and pro
boxing. That's not out of
the question. Oh my God,
he's going to 55 I think probably for me
at 45 let's be, well, I mean who knows,
man. I mean, he seems to be this.
If he makes it through five
rounds looking like this,
we've got to shut the fuck up cause
he made 45 and he's like, oh my God,
doesn't matter.
He's looking fantastic and less.
They can make a case for him to fight
Mcgregor. He 55 they should. Yes.
If 55 deep supercars never
coming down to 45 for him.
But I would feel like if I
was, if I was all though, look,
you have to be co undeniable.
Oh my God. And at 30 years old,
he can become undeniable still. He's
still, I mean to us, to the hardcore fans,
he's undenying undeniable.
But in order to sell that big paper view
that would make Connor want to catch
her breath, get your revenge.
He's got a merch. Everybody. Yeah.
He's got to become this guy like Gennady
Golovkin like we're to the point where
like Canelo had to fight him.
Everybody keeps talking about Golovkin
go up and go walking. Oh good.
What happens if Josie Aldo came up and
fought fucking cubbies or Tony Ferguson
worked them crazy. Connor almost forced
to crazy. Yeah. It's talking shit.
Yeah, and Merck and Tony.
I'll tell you that much.
I knew you were going to say that.
I'm just saying.
Oh No, it's too much. Oh no, he's missing.
I feel like Tony is so
fucking durable and so nasty.
Just like such a natural fighter.
He is to be so game,
but also super smart.
Super Skillful and disciplined is,
fuck. Tony's a handful for
anybody. Anybody, anybody.
I need to see him in fucking
could be fine. And I know, man.
You know what Tony should just ask
him like, hey man, what do you weigh?
65 let's just fire you.
Don't die. Don't die.
Oh,
oh
punches. I don't have any
tag. I'm actually, oh, oh
man. It's beautiful to have that. Very
best can not a whole lot of kicking folks.
Cause I didn't just say as a phrase is
going to catch her right hand if he kicks.
Although I mean,
I'll tell you what though.
Max is showing his fight Iq man,
he's,
he's showing his fight Iq click how he's
stretching those arms out in front of
them. He's, he's giving that
doubt. Good. Connor is he'd
beat both these dudes. Yeah,
but also like you see how he's doing that?
First of all,
he's doing it totally legal code
head. Oh God. With the right.
Again, this is crazy. Hey Connor, beat
him to with a torn knee, by the way.
I don't want to hear about that. Oh,
body kick Dan, they're going off now.
Ooh Man. Strong kick to the
body. Bags back. Holy Shit.
We'll fight.
What a fight Matt want that Max has a
motherfucking savage was all though,
man. You know what? If you take away that
one punch by Connor is the best ever.
He's pampered. Found number one crazy.
I would say it's crazy. Did take that,
but he did take that hit ain't done
a bit so you know what it is, man.
It's like here's a
puzzle to every fighter.
The question is did he seal that puzzle
problem up that little hole that Connor
founded? These seal that up. Any
fights kind? We won't know. Damn it.
They have to fight. That could be
fine. If you were the head of the UFC,
would you be like, listen, we got to
make this happen boys? No, I let you do.
I would have Conner probably fight
GSP forced on him fight Florida. GSP
want people to be educated.
I want Oh, nice jam man.
I want people to feel about sites
and the way we feel about fights.
You know what I'm saying? I
hear you. I got one people
hands up. Hands down. Oh.
Oh Man. Slash bitch slapped him. Oh Shit.
Oh well you be careful.
Max was trying to give them the
up and I'll know. Turn his back.
So Max lost a psychological war there.
He gave a thumbs up to do on his
back to him. That's not good,
right? Max Holloway's that
guy though, you think? Oh, uh,
yeah. I mean probably right. If you had
a guest, he's down. He's down for sure.
It's clean. That's quick.
Clean. He looks good.
I love it. I love it. I love
it. And look and see that.
Oh, he gave the thumb to
his back. Never win a case.
You gotta be quick Paul.
No fucking cheese.
And you've got a double and you meet
might need to walk towards him after that.
Yeah, right. Yeah. You gotta you gotta
you might come up with a game plan.
No stool in between rounds now.
Yup. No, no, it's dangerous is,
although he's got high level chokes.
Oh yeah,
man.
I'm not mad.
I thought about,
he's Jujitsu going on here at all.
I'm going to and mustache
bodied up in this great head.
Mr. Steal your girl at that picture.
Right?
Okay, so here's the question. We're
in the round three now, right?
It's four 44 max down to the
speed I would say. Right?
If you had to look at this scorecard,
but interesting rounds, right?
The Max has got his both guys
who've gotten things off,
but all though it looks fucking sensation,
the second rounds will inch in
the first round. I was like, well,
mixed bucket span and please
make a tee shirts. You're crazy.
I was interested in the first round.
I'm saying that first round though,
Max really got outclassed.
I don't think there was something
that was a big long period.
The beginning of where was waiting for
somebody to move true and then although
eventually got the best of the exchanges,
he's just showing some really nice levels
trying to get them back kicked back to
what the, Oh nope. He's letting him
out. Oh my God. This is some, oh,
here's the other thing you got.
How many wars?
All those already been in a real fight.
They took a lot out of them as the
Chad Mendez thing though. I mean,
and also Connor, he's had
to Ricardo, Ricardo, lamas,
fight lamas had him on his
back and he's punched him.
Dominic [inaudible] crazy,
but he was on antibiotics when he was
a shit's getting knocked guide yet.
Brendan,
please
both of them all with that.
Sweet. Neat. I know. I don't know.
I'm hating on all though.
I don't get it. Oh,
I max the wind for some reason.
You know what?
One of the best things that's
ever happened at a being
a commentator is learning
how to appreciate just a performance.
It's got favorites.
I always had favorites, man.
Always when I was early. Right.
I try
not to now, but like if somebody that I'm
friends with like of cowboy fights, oh,
it's the worst. It's hard. It's hard
for me. Very, very hard for me to call.
Your fights were the hardest
I've ever had a call.
Really hundred percent so
hard as I've ever had a call.
So you have to like decide
like, oh, oh my God.
Oh, he's hurting. It's not over yet.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Hello?
Oh, she'll grappling going on
right. Tagged him again. Oh,
let him up. I'll do is let them
hire street. Oh my goodness.
Make him get up Max and knocked
him out. Oh, what heart? Heart.
Heart is right heart by
Aldo to survive this.
He's too his Jujitsu,
but side your trolls.
Look at this alive. Oh
Shit. He's so battered, man.
Oh,
Halloween.
Oh my goodness.
No more burger joints. Oh
fuck man. Dude. He might,
you never know what the fuck it now I
know. No more burger joints. Think Max is
trying to sneak out the back door. What
did you get to try and do is use. Oh,
he's showing under the chin. He's
got it. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God,
Dude.
This dude is hurting a lot of time.
Oh my God.
What's rough is that, oh, that's a big
job. And he knows what he's doing. Oh,
head arm. Drag it all the time. The
wrong, right. Arm's the wrong spot. Oh,
well this is, if he just pours it on
right now, he's going to stop. Come on.
No, no, no, no. Oh my goodness.
He's defending. Oh my goodness.
Get the arm. Get the arm. Does a
cover up. Cover up now what now?
What is it he's going to say?
Defend Yourself. Defend your no,
GC and I'm good.
Okay.
I often hear that last fight,
but when I shut up and yet,
oh,
oh wow.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit.
Hawaii finally gets the rural champ.
God Damn fucking Hawaii.
Holy Shit. Max Holloway.
You know what, man? Aldo,
he's shaking his head because he still
wanted to be able to fight and it's a
referee's called the stop, the fight,
and he, he's very upset about that.
He was stuck, but man,
it seemed legit to me.
That was a legit stoppage. It seemed
legit to me. I see my intelligent, oh,
you know it's legit.
Eddie had
cruelty. Oh yeah. You think it's legit,
right? Yeah, I do. Yeah, I would.
I would imagine there could be.
You have to protect the,
the road I liked. I liked that.
That big John let it go that long.
But you rarely see he took a beating
for like two minutes straight.
Yup. Yup. Came back, man. You got tagged
so hard, man. She sees what he goes
through, man. What an incredible fight.
Madison.
Oh,
let him jump in the
fucking flag flag, man. No,
there's this family that flew all the
way from Hawaii. My where's the rock?
What the fuck up man?
You got a world champion in Hawaii
like Cleveland. We got a world champ.
Cleveland. We got to world
chesty pay. That's right.
That's one of my all time favorite. A guy
who just won the title things is steep.
Emile chick did Cleveland's, he
said he ran out onto the cage.
He couldn't believe it after
he knocked out his last fight.
Kelly. Right? You like him?
You like machine gun? Kelly
say something nice or say nothing at all.
Hey listen,
there's a serious movement in Cleveland.
Yeah, well listen, Cleveland is a,
I had a great fucking time.
We did a UFC in Cleveland just
a little while ago and I did.
I did a show there in Cleveland.
I had a fucking great time,
man. They're fun, Dude.
That clip that city's coming back to
life. Hawaii, Whitney lucky and come back.
Let's look at this big
bang. Boom. Come on.
Sign drops him with that
right hand. Nothing fancy. Is
it the one to the one, two.
Beautiful timing though, man. Beautiful
timing. Look at this. Look at that.
Oh my timing with that
right hand is perfection.
He's on top of him dropping bombs on him.
There was a couple of times in the fight
where it looks like it looked like Aldo
went out, but his will, his will and
his need to fucking get through this.
Like right there, Bang. Come on man.
Is to be Josie Aldo once in that kind of
freak fight with Conor to beat him like
this. I mean, Max Holloway
beat the shit out of him.
He beat him in a way that
no one's ever beat him,
matched his best and kept going to him
and he beat him in a way that no one's
ever beat him.
Connor only beat him cause he caught him.
Max Holloway beat him down and beat him.
Beat him down.
Got through the gauntlet.
How big is that tall?
We can be Hawaii and fighting
his fucking dry aunt.
I've been singing happy as
Bj Penn and own that island.
I've been singing that kids
praises for a long time.
He came into the UFC super poor Joseph.
Oh yeah.
The background holding that
devastated like it's his man.
Hey Man. Hey Man. It is what it did.
Did a great job. He's a great fighter.
It is what it is. This is fighting
and people win and people lose.
And the the sport ultimately,
it depends upon the sort of fights.
It depends upon these all time greats
like Aldo facing some guy who's got the
solution to what that guy presents. Yup.
And that's what although did tonight.
How do you mean?
He went out there with all
of his championship medal
and he laid it all on the
line. He fought his best and his
puzzle got solved by the new breed.
Let's hear,
let's hear what he has.
Both these guys give us some volume
cause I know how to be a beat.
Him with a torn ACL title wrapped
around it a long time ago still.
It's incredible.
Diploma. [inaudible] Jesus
Christ. Second of all got,
I got a his son at home. Maybe
Russia. You got another phone baby.
Josh Holloway. Great man. I
love it. George Rush. Saint
Pierre Inspired Nasser. No.
Nah,
he's Hawaiian.
You now though. You're on your phone,
don't you man. You guys bike brands.
I love you guys.
[inaudible]
John, powerful shout out to Brazil. Always
a good move. Yeah, but they're boring.
They're pulling them.
Well of course they're booing them.
They feel like the fight shouldn't have
been stopped because their guy got beat.
You're smiling that Brazil
started a little slow tonight.
Then round three when you've got slow,
why you gotta bring up Oh shit.
Sarah,
you had been away.
What? My 50 games. He read
the decision, right? Bang.
I'm a smart QC. Hawaii. Wow. That's
Tom UFC. Hawaii. We'd very tough shit.
I don't know.
I don't travel overseas,
but I will fucking fly
to Hawaii in a heartbeat.
I will that make it happen.
How about we do a joint show
up in that mother fucker?
We miss a
show.
Yeah.
How about we do a fight companion
in Hawaii if they do a UFC in a,
why we all fly out to Hawaii and do
some sort of a fight camp painted,
you know Hawaii. So even if I
don't work in that, we still there.
Let's be in Hawaii. Yeah. Let's see if
we can get a fight. Companion booth.
Let's just cut the shit.
Okay.
I can do a viking penguin at the show.
This is, this is what I'm thinking. This
is the kind of commentary I liked doing.
So what we need to do,
because you need to treat the
fight companion like an embassy.
Like we have our own special country
rules slash just put us right in their
life.
Yes.
I want to see bringing Jamie Hall
and let us do commentary. You don't
have to listen. You got other options.
You can listen to the Tories. You can
listen to the corner options, right.
You can tell daddy shops,
you can listen to it in Brazil.
You can listen to it in Portuguese. Is
that green screen? I think I find sweet.
Like can you just sit down with Tom
White and have a fucking conversation?
We're going to be better one of
those suites instead of ring side.
If we did it I see four
season and watch it.
We could totally or we can just keep
doing it for me but we're not getting
enough playing for [inaudible] here.
Did you imagine if they collapse
of that in fight companion,
if that was one of the options like you
get fight companion or in a fight pass
you get fight companion, you don't
eat. The ratings would go up and fight.
Kiki contacted you that he
decided that it's not a good idea.
Come on man.
Really started long ago.
We have talked about on
the fence head of files.
We may keep those motherfuckers away.
Is 42,000 people watching
right now that many.
Is that a record? I don't
know, man records. Alex Jones,
right? Yeah. It was like 60 songs.
Jesus, I forget. People here can watch.
That's a lot of the stadium watching.
How about Derrick Lewis? Mark Hunt.
Look at that fight I got. I should have
done my hair. Bronson, Daniel, Kelly,
Daniel Kelly might just
be able to beat everybody.
There's something weird about that dude.
He has some weird old man thing going
on. I can shoot dope thing, man.
The competitor thing. Double knee braces.
Right? It's crazy. These are fucks up.
I asked him about it after the last time
I interviewed him after a fight and he
said if he wasn't fighting he
would get surgery. Fuck he said,
but as long as they let him tape
the fuck out of his niece. Dude,
he's like a mummy. All judo guys. But
like usually judo people I've built,
all their needs are their needs,
their needs get jacked.
God Damn Max Holloway so long
as punch fast little champ,
man Holloway would that I fucking long
punch. But although countered them not,
oh look at that woman's amazing.
Although countered him and
hit him some real big shops.
That's how good mass,
you know, it's crazy.
Some people thought maybe cubs swats.
We'll get the next shop up.
Max fucking annihilated cub.
Yeah. Well, you know what?
Here's what's important about this fight.
It's not just at Max. Holloway did this,
but that Max Holloway did this
to a Aldo Max Holloway left.
No doubt in anyone's mind.
This is the best 145 pound
fighter on the planet earth.
If you look at how all though God
pass Frankie Edgar, you look at it,
although God passed everybody except
for Connor, and then you look,
you know the car's not
coming down to one 45 more.
That's the motherfucker right there. And
he made an ecstatic tonight. Holloway.
Frankie,
you're well,
hey gift you then what in the world,
don't you think that your Yahya Rodriguez
has two forks in the road, right?
There's the fork of unrealized potential.
So he comes into this fight.
He's got Bj Penn behind him, right? He'll
nylon. It's Bj Penn. He hits Bj Penn,
one of the greatest of all time hall of
Famer with a three 60 round kick to the
neck.
That just doesn't happen right?
Then he gets murked by frank steroid
and so he has, yes, he's not ready,
but he has two paths.
Like either he can learn from how Frankie
was able to take him down and beat the
fuck out of him and then figure out a
way to never let that happen again or be
overwhelmed by the pressure of that loss
and the circumstances and the sorrow
depends on his mindset. Also
depends on match. Looks like.
I like [inaudible] Holloway.
That's a great,
very good fats hallways and
I can take him down. Sorry.
It just striking for Stryker of both
45 hours. That's a great fight Gavin.
Almost. It'd be damn near even money.
I bet. Yeah, but I guarantee you,
you're going to see Max
Holloway taking people down to,
I think that dude is smart as fuck,
but he keeps adding to his,
he's not going to take Frankie now.
You're right.
Their buddies from Kratos listen,
extra foot reach it. But Joel,
there's really no grapple.
A lot of grapplers left,
right Frankie, you're right.
Frankie's the big threat.
If you're a guy who can't stop and take
down the number one threat is Frankie
and the white, give him a year.
Why would you give him the one guy
he eating your own young. You're
eating your young. You say that
you believe in protecting fighters.
You get a guy like Jon Jones,
Jon Jones youngest ever does a flying
knee in his opening move against Shogun.
Right? But look what he did. But
that's what makes those guys,
that's a hard case though
because a couple of good fights.
But that hard case because you don't give
him to a grappler like Frankie knowing
that the guy cannot stop taking all time,
gave him time to develop and give them
the other guys who are very exciting
strikers cause he's, he's a star.
John before he won the title,
had some very good fights,
but it's real good fights where
after he got the title four,
which showed Brandon Vera
cradled Ryan banner that Dante Tez fight
with w w the Stephan Bonner fight was
one of the most interesting ones
because he showed up creative. It was,
and he shows single-leg spinning
elbow. He showed up creative. He is,
and he showed up.
Fluid is moving is,
and it just showed that he was on another
level. He never got that. But also, yeah,
you're like, he had a split decision
win over Bruce Leroy. Right.
Very good point. And then they're like,
oh here's Frankie Uyghur. It's like God.
Yeah,
it's a very good point because I feel
like he felt so good after the Bj Penn
fight. He felt like he had
arrived and he's like that Alex,
cause Sarah's fight is out the window.
I'm fucking past that now.
And he might have been, but he wasn't.
There's just this disease levels now.
It is buddy.
Everybody that knows anybody
in any kind of martial art,
whether it's boxing or
wrestling or Jujitsu,
there's always people who overestimate
their proficiency. Pronounce sure.
Get some more. Uh, you quit that
earthy show. This is your fruity.
That's your California. But the boys
nine boys night, we're hanging in Italy.
I'm fucking super impressive.
Max Holloway, man. Super
depressed him say frank,
yet that's coming. There isn't the
only 25. How old is Max Holloway?
Now I want to say he got into the UFC
when he was either 20 or 20 years in
Hawaii, Hawaii together like
fucking peanut butter and Jelly man.
They fucking love fighting. Cause
Bj, Bj started that man. Dude,
listen champ. Yeah, and a legit champion.
Just beat who is arguably one of the great
look I gotta say Conners the greatest
145 pounder of all time because he
knocked out all the WHO's clearly,
but it terms of like, who's got more
victories? Of course it's all though body,
the body of work. But the, the
problem is, the ultimate question is,
it's not,
we're not doing MMA math here.
You having two guys
actually fight each other?
So if you said like who
the greatest of all time?
Well it would have to be all go because he
beat all these guys. No, no, no, no, no.
Because the two of them fought and Connor
murked up Corinna so you got to give
it to him.
Otherwise there's no other metric.
There's no other metric
other than a knockout.
What happened was is that it's the most
important body of the sign with the
flathead.
Be penalize for beating someone easily.
I mean like you beat them
to easily say doesn't count.
We had a really good lucky down,
but this is what is in the locker room.
They show him do the exact combo.
Yeah. Like it wasn't like a freak,
like oh my God,
please show him step back,
throw the exact cup and this is
what's going to happen. Yup. Yeah.
And they also showed him do that front
leg side kick to the leg. It's nice.
He created the distance.
He's hopping in and out and he wanted to
slide back and countered with that left
hand. He hit it perfect. He
called. He's the best ever.
You have to say he's the best ever. Even
if you never fights featherweight again.
Why? Because he kao the
best ever. The real,
the reality is all those the best ever.
But Connor Kod,
you couldn't say without the Aldo
fight that Connor was the best ever.
Cause you look at all the different people
that both of them fall. You're like,
wow, it's really close. It's
really interesting. But within Wa,
but although I was more fights,
but then once they actually fight,
which is all that, that's all
it matters. All that matters.
Not Mma match your right to competition.
They file it is, I mean that,
so you got to give it to the light
and people will fight against it. No,
because all those, the champion for
so many years, you're 100% right.
His body of work as much more impressive
and there's always going to be an
asterisk next to Connor because you know
there was just this one time he fought
for the title at one 45 k owed all though.
Y'All be cool.
Y'All be cool here,
come get it. So it's really
clear. It's really clear.
There are tied for the best
guy in the shirt. And then
what's the tie breaker? Oh,
their fight. They got what happened in the
fight? You decide, right? You know what?
You know what's interesting?
It's really simple,
but sometimes like you'll get top ten's,
you'll look at a guy who's number six
and then the guy who was number eight
knocked him out in the last fight.
And you're like,
what in the fuck is going body
of work? That's crazy. I know.
It was an upset.
He got lucky.
Like it says who when it got punches you
in the face and wanted to punch you in
the face and then punched you in
the face. Where's the luck? We,
what are you doing? He
rolling. I caught him.
But when Tom off hand that fats to be in
the argument of the best ever liked for
all though to be in the argument and
from Mcgregor or for anybody. John Jones,
like just to be in the goddamn argument.
Oh man,
it's the best ever know what it was in
fade or, or is it, um, Anderson Anderson?
Who is it? Is it facing? Those are
the two arms. That's the two argument.
I'm always been in the Anderson.
Kim Jones is in there. No, not yet.
I think you still could because his body
of work, he could, but there's so much,
there's so many problems with that. So
many problems with that. Off the field.
Pick the OSP problem. You know, we
were, he had a good fight, I think.
I think you've performed well.
Gets a really dangerous slick guy,
but he didn't put on a show cave. Then
Anderson Silva has the Damien Maia fight,
the towel size,
those horrible fights,
favorite or had some insights
to Anderson had those earlier.
And then he started dominating people.
And when you look at some of the crazy
Anderson fights like the Forrest Griffin
Kao, when you look at Anderson
like motivated Anderson,
when he's like in shape and
the James Irvin, when he
went up to two oh five jobs,
I know it's true,
but when you see him as an assassination,
it's Vitor Belfort Vietor who
named Mark Horton is price.
They talk TRT Victoria go through John
Show Gun. You know what I'm saying?
That's not true. It wasn't
Trt v tour back then. No.
Veto wasn't on TRT and became
on TRT factory fight Anderson.
He looked different when he
fought Anderson. He was like,
he didn't like John [inaudible].
Jack [inaudible] was Vito when he was
19 is that still considered DRTV for no,
no, no. He said that
he was two 42 40 with
a side of the picture.
Sheriff Jim [inaudible]
and I met his trainer way,
way back in the day. We used to call
them garden hoses. I remember him,
I remember him
35 years old.
Joe and I were looking at him.
He was thinking he was Joe.
And I remember the airborne memory,
he was eating wars put.
Of course he's eating out of a can of
tuna at the airport and he and I were
watching her and Joe goes like,
this was looking at a good job. US,
he is the color of aplomb
cause crazy dude.
You never seen anybody that he was,
he was just a totally different,
it's called pressure.
It's supposed to be was
like in everyone's corner.
Anderson Silva's with a fanny pack and
just call them garden hoses because we
worked out with him once and a
dude had garden hoses from Hanes.
I think that was his,
nick was his name growing and I think
we might have mentioned it either.
You and I are but, but it was, but
yeah, he died. Yeah. Yeah Dude.
And this is when too much gear. This is
when Vito was in the Randy couture fight.
So this was the,
those days when Vito looked like a lion,
it looks like a male line. Schuman,
lion, like his neck started.
Nobody had better training about
here.
I just came straight down and he was
just super jack when he fought Randy.
He was like two 40 yes, he's
fighting money. Any five now.
Just stop and a tough lady. Five. Just
stop and think of that. That is insane.
I mean that's insane.
Themed out garden hose down.
No. You remember the other fist fight?
Rockhold is Tiara TV? Do you remember?
There's another fistfight.
Here's a trivia question for Joe Rogan.
There was a fist fight in the stands
after [inaudible] lost to Randy couture.
Do you remember who it was between?
Um,
was that the one between tank
Abbott? Nope. No. Who Was it? Nope.
It's how it was always getting.
It was a fist fight between Gemma
fee tourism mom and his girlfriend.
Who's that dude? Dude's that Curtis? Yeah.
Yeah. There he is. That's Mr. Hose. Oh,
is that handles the dude
across the shoulder?
Pull up is a go go big on his
images. Good. Just, just, just,
just does that, but that's him. Just go
big. Make it big. Like close it. Sorry.
Yeah. Look at the size of
his fucking veins, dude.
We'd be at the gym with them be like,
well, how come we don't look like that?
Because that doesn't even look like
a human. That dude was so jacked.
He's super nice guys, biceps,
everything. If he right there,
right with edit where his elbow is
like, what is that? That's like,
it's a keyboard,
like a steroid that he took some stuff.
He just fucking biceps right by the side
of the steroids because they always say
no one's died from steering.
Know your heart.
It can fuck with your lipid levels and
everything we do. If you do it that much.
God knows what he was taking pictures
on cow blood. He was taking crazy.
People take a lot of crazy stuff.
They also take insulin and apparently
that's really dangerous in the kitchen.
There's a lot of different stuff that
they tell you. He took a lot of stuff.
All of it is effective if you want
to get to that fucking giant size,
you know? I'm trying to get on
man, I've got to contact him.
We've been going back and forth. Is Dorian
Yates. Ooh, that'd be fun. Fuck Cam man.
He's going to be, he's going to be
about July giant man. Openly. Yeah.
It tells us dosages do says what he
was doing. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Talking about it. Still doing it
now. Well, he does. He's on TRT now.
Talks about that.
Cause we had Phil,
he thought he was Mister Olympia seven
time Mister Olympia. And you go really?
Like you can't like I want to get
steroids. No, we don't humpy come on.
Dorian Yates brings it up himself.
He wants to talk about it. He's like,
this is crazy. Like everybody should know
what we're doing and there are no nuts.
His credit, Arnold says the same thing,
aren't it? Tells everybody about it too.
Yeah.
They were all there.
I mean obviously there's no
one way to achieve both sizes.
Yes. Terminators on this too. There's
no way to achieve those sizes.
If you're not taking something.
He's kind of still doing something.
All those pictures of her wants to be
on steroids.
Oh, you fixed now. He's in shape now to,
Amy's going to have to
terminate her ice off dad. You
guys know he had heart surgery.
Yes.
That's when he looked disgusting on the
beach. That's what was going on. I mean,
he had a lay lay low.
Let his body were counseling him,
especially alone in the hospital.
If you don't work out,
but he, he's bald. He's bald.
Jack now. God. Holy Shit.
Photoshop maybe. Right.
That can't be real. Now he's getting
help. Is that real dance him? He's jacked.
Oh my God. And Franco Columbo. That's
real shit. He's back. Look at him.
That's his son right there, right? Well,
you know what he's doing. It's not that
recent Gold's gym son.
What he's been saying,
what he's been saying is that he's,
he's been working out with Franco
Columbo and him and Franco Columbo travel
around together and they work out
together. [inaudible] Franco Columbo.
Those dudes were the shit back in the
day and the body and both of them are
added again. Well, both of
them were on a fucking picture.
Yes. There's a bunch of follow up.
He could personally, he can blow up.
Franco Columbo would do two things.
One is he could go dip shit that's from
that movie pumping and pumping iron and
shit.
He used to do dips with two girls hanging
off his legs and he can blow up one of
those old fashion water bladders. You know
those ones you fill up hot water bath.
He can,
he can fill up like to the boys back
hold on. Weekends. Franco Columbia
could make it explode. God Damn,
he didn't blow it up.
He blew it up and made it pop and Jay z,
he did it in like 30 seconds. That's
how strong saying, just with his power,
his lung power,
he was one of the most
powerful bodybuilders and he's
one of the smallest. Yes.
Power. It wasn't a big guy, please.
I was never going to jerk off on
a guy I'm in most of the time.
I'm not thinking about it.
They go to a gym,
they're like Lyft and people watch them.
They just go to the gym together, man. Oh,
that's cool. Like if you and
me went to the gym together,
they go to the gym together.
Go guys.
Two old guys fucking went at it could
mean Callen went to the gym together.
We're getting old bunny, but frankly we're
on the way to those people. Yes, we are.
Franco's not on any testosterone though.
What are you talking about?
He's hanging out with Arnold
and he's, he's like, okay,
well how many milligrams to
bring up Franco right now? Nice.
Had a question for you. Yeah, hold on.
We've got two different conversations
going on. I'm sorry. Gun to your head.
Got a gun to your head and you've got
to jerk off on anybody in man's face on
the planet. Who would it be?
Donald Trump. No, hold on.
So this is as long as long as
that size.
So it wouldn't necessarily
be my favorite American, but
I like what? He's not American, but
don't listen to me. Look at me say no.
Hold on. Absolutely not. Nothing
but respect for Heather Hector love.
I love Hector Lombard.
I would never,
he's saying because he don't
even bring a gun to your head.
You don't want to no, no, no, no,
no. I will never, I would never,
I would never splurge on a guy that
I respected as a two level library.
I like Jude law.
I know where you went with
that. Now hold on. Johnny Depp.
[inaudible] mother fuckers got to hold
his hand and they'll get me in the eye
and I have to go like this. I got
to go. Hey listen man. I spent
[inaudible] was the 50s
movie was the 50s movie.
What was it? Cold outside. It just got
to go back to him and the outsiders.
I'm 50 21 jump street,
you know,
tried to hate your but this
moment because I'm 50 is it
not shooting heavy?
She got a baby bird.
If you came on his face and he caught
those teeth, you'd feel bad. Right?
The snuggle t look at
if you saw your own cup
first just to look like Photoshop. Know
Brian. He used to have terrible teeth,
dammit.
Oh my God.
I think they actually added a shark tooth.
Well that's him after braces.
He had braces when he was like
40 that'd be braces in veneers.
Yellow teeth were also off to one side.
I want to know how he got, I want to know
the story of how he got in. Is there a,
is there a video out there?
Scientology.
How did he get in? Like what
happened? That's a good question.
I think somebody recruited them
from a movie. He was good though.
He was already at movies.
He was
the guy who made that happen
on Scientology.
There's like season for
my podcast. She talked about it
and you know, when I first met her,
she was deep in it.
She was with Kevin James,
she was on king and Queens and that's
when I first met her and he was like,
she's a scientologist, was like, Woo.
She's really nice. She's very cool man.
That's just QT to mind. Control
keys. That's all that is. Well,
somebody figured out how to control people
long time ago.
It's called come up with a set of rules
and say that this is like someone's
looking out for this set of rules,
whether it's God or Buddha
or creating mythology.
Do is do that and people follow it.
It's the stuff that,
until they know nothing but reports of,
uh,
child abuse, it just gives a
lot cheaper using colts. Yeah.
It's one of the big problems with cults.
Joey Diaz,
his ex girlfriends was in a cult like
when she was a kid and he, she said that,
uh, the guy who was the head of the
call molested everybody. Of course.
Less it all the girls. Yeah. Molested.
He wanted to fuck everybody's one. Yeah.
It's all just, that's cool.
Yeah. That's all these calls.
That's what happened. Polygamy.
Waco, crazy. David Koresh.
That's the crazy thing.
David Koresh. They shut that
motherfucker shit. The down.
We are allowing this to happen.
It's like we want it to happen.
It's like it's a CIA.
Mk Ultra Express.
Well, what do you mean? Well,
I realize,
look at the time,
let me feed the beast riders on the
storm. I don't know shit. I don't know
how, and when you look into it, you
got to look in the, look into it.
I've been living into it.
Think about this.
Think about how crazy that religion
is. Yeah. Think about that.
Think about how it's allowed
to survive and thrive.
You seemed like Scientology even better.
I'll do you one better.
Scientology doesn't have to pay taxes.
Hold on. I'll tell you, I'll
tell you the kitchen, the facts,
I'm not taking the actual fact.
They organized a massive lawsuit
campaign against the IRS.
And they said that if you can say
that all these different religions,
whether it's Catholicism or Mormonism,
Mormonism has very
questionable backgrounds.
More minutes was started by Joseph
Smith who was a known con man.
I mean Mormonism course.
It's, yeah, there's,
there's like he found it when he was
14 he said he found golden tablets that
contained the loss work of Jesus and only
he could read him cause he had a magic
seer stone.
Like when you look at the actual,
you're talking about a guy who we know
the guy, right? So Scientology was like,
well so fucking what if you can take that?
If you'd take Mormonism,
like why can't we get tax exempt
status? And they said, no, fuck you.
You're not a real religion. And
they're like bullshit. If, if,
if anything is a religion where religion
and in that sense I support them.
I don't think, I think all
religions should have to pay taxes.
But I think that if
anybody gets a free ride,
so I told you you should get a free ride.
If you're going to have this
goofy loophole, then they qualify.
If Mormons get up to, that's what happened
at he is massive lawsuits. It was the,
and this is all you could find it.
I saw it, I saw the ideal document.
They filed a Shitload of lawsuits and
the IRS was fuck you talking about going
clear the gaskets, amazing books, amazing
doc. It's a great, the books even better.
Great because it goes into
the history of this big book.
Everything's allowed to happen.
The thing is no one can pay
attention to everything.
Everything is allowed to happen all
the time and then once we find out that
something's happening and
it's like, okay, now what?
You can't shut down a religion?
Well,
you can't shut down anybody's freedom
of speech. If you have an ideology,
your freedom of expression,
your your ability to gather and talk,
no shit. All I know is if,
if I had a country to run,
I would start.
If I was running in the country,
I would start colts and have mind
control experiments with too,
but I wouldn't have time in between
negotiating oil deals and trying to figure
out whether or not we should stay then
NATO and prime it Paris climate control.
I know what you're saying and
you know in a way you're right,
but no one has the time to do ever is
not enough to micro manage the entire
world business. Right. It's just there's,
there's only so much shit you
can let people take care of them.
You could let people take care of
themselves. Illuminati got key,
got enough time for mind
control experiments.
There's too much shit going on.
Well,
they definitely have done some
mind control experiments too.
That's part of the problem around
the country. I'm thinking of.
I'm saying Goodbye Comic Book Guy
Writes Comic Books. I would definitely
read who you're going to start a religion.
You're going to start a religion.
You're going to start and just,
you're going to bullshit in this way
and we're going to who? Who is right.
I want to know from you and you better
tell me my country at least 500 years old.
The candy. Oh it's, you know
it. You have a question,
Brian, you got to tell me this,
cause I know you know the fucking answer,
but as a dictator hold other.
I want you to ask
your finger on the post.
I want to know right now on this
podcast who was running this country.
I have no idea. Come on Bro. I don't know.
Give me a little idea cause I know
you got to fucking, I don't know Bro.
You're out. You're playing dumb
right now. I'm going to guess,
I'm going to guess based
on circumstantial evidence.
I'm going to Oprah. The guests, uh,
educating guys, control the banks. That's,
I don't know who would they
be Roth trials. I Dunno. I
could be wrong with that.
Slippy Rothschild's could be a complete
none of the application. That's an,
I don't know. I looked up on the day
in the Rothschilds like a family.
Here's what's hilarious.
It's 1 billion to like 70 trillion,
700 trillion,
700 billion or trillion
number lays it there.
The amount of money they own.
It's either one a billion. Oh,
a hundred percent surreal.
Oh, 100% there's a family
that owns all the banks. No.
There is a family that has a
considerable amount of money.
They pass down from generation generation
and these, these young, the Saturations,
how much figured out how
to connect in the real.
We don't use it. We don't
know. That's what they say.
They say between 1,000,000,700
zillion. Nope. Says 500 trucks.
But do they even exist to the rob trials
even exists? That could be a conspiracy.
Can I say one thing? The
Rothschilds are a hoax. Okay.
Think about the Rock Charles.
When, when you talk about the Ross,
Charles and these different big families,
if there's one thing in common,
it's a hoax. Nope, follow me on this if
you hear it. Nope. They're all Jewish.
And by the way, if you look at their
roots, if you look at the roots of these,
a lot of these, a lot of these rumors,
a lot of these rumors and conspiracies,
they start in the the free mail,
not to cams.
And the ultra right wing camps
and a lot of the antisemetic anti,
you know the history that goes way back,
that goes way back into Europe.
That goes way back with the Nazi.
So just be careful where
these things come from.
You'll find that there are roots. No, I
know. I don't know shit. I'm on Youtube.
Yeah, their roots sometimes
starting really at off places.
So you should read a
book every now and then.
The guy who's had clear and the looming
tower, two very good books. I Dunno.
The plant paradox, which I'm reading
now about food, very interesting.
Benefits me to believe something unless
I make money from it. Yeah. Idiot.
You're a fucking idiot. You know,
like what is, if I believe this dude,
you could be fucking,
your kids could be go to college
if you want measurable results.
If you just sign off and
say you believe it, like uh,
that's not what's going to happen.
Is it illegal? If I don't believe it,
well I get thrown in jail.
No, then I don't want to.
If I don't want to believe Shit,
if it,
if it doesn't hurt me I it
shouldn't be such a big deal.
That's you know, that's, I
don't know what to believe man.
I don't know if the Rothschilds are real.
I Dunno if reptilians are real.
I don't know. Satanism is real. I don't
know. Shit. One thing I'd say is learning,
getting closer to the truth can be
achieved by looking at all the independent
lines of inquiry.
All the independent lines come to one
consensus to come to the truth is that
you're trying to tell me
exactly how to come up.
I'm just saying generally I'm spelling
in general cause I would never tell you
to get closer. Come on. Come on
man. I'm talking about Janet.
Let me say this cause I think
this is really important.
One of the problems that I've had me
personally I've had with any idea is that
once I have an original idea, a, once I
start looking at something a certain way,
I become married to it. Yes. And
I bet real problems with that.
And the problem is half. It's
confirmation bias. I understand.
But I'm just saying I've
had real problems with that.
Like personally where I had to look
at like what I believed and go,
well why do I believe that and why?
Why do I think,
and there's been a bunch of times
whether it's your big foot or Ufos or,
I mean I've looked at the
JFK assassination a hundred
different fucking times.
You know, there's been times when I
said, well maybe Oswald got lucky me.
Like people do get lucky.
Like I,
I've shot the first animal I ever shot.
I shot at 200
yards and I probably shouldn't have had
it dropped. I could have fucked that up.
You know, you can, if
you're aiming at something,
pull the trigger and hit the president
in the back of the head. It is possible.
I don't think it did. It seems to me
more like some other shit was going on.
If you look at all the
different pieces of evidence,
but I don't fucking know man.
And the problem with saying this happened,
that happened, which I used to do all
the time, is that you don't fucking know.
You don't know. You don't know until
you do know when you say you know,
and you might be wrong, it becomes an
ego thing. So you can speculate. Yes,
you can get closer to the truth. She would
approximate. So if you hear scientists,
they always say it's so fascinating.
Scientist start always with doubt and
what they do is they always say if you
really corner signs that say,
well this is the most likely, uh,
based on the data I've looked at are
the literature I've read carefully.
This is the most likely possibility.
It's really interesting to hear how they
talk that way because like with global
warming or anything, if you're not Kraus,
uh, yes, it's across the house. Listen,
I've had him on my podcast.
I listened to both the podcasts you had
with them and try to read some of his
book. It was tough. But yes,
I love book is rough dude.
When he started to have to
have a back age symmetry,
when he was going to gauge symmetry and
I fucked up by opening up my podcast,
asking him to explain gauge symmetry.
Now I know it's insane.
I got, this is what I got some hole in
your head. I got the, there's a web,
there's an invisible web and we come
into contact with w w we, we become mass,
but we have to understand is
skepticals we are of this shit.
These are the same motherfuckers they
put together the large Hadron Collider,
Sierra spinning Adams just slightly
under the speed of light slamming,
admitted to each other and recreating
the very instances right after the big
bang and they're doing that shit
right. Crazy. There's a team of sign.
How many sides does 130 countries?
Thousands. Thousands. Guys, find out.
How many of you guys all agree that
Nikola Tesla was a great scientist? Oh,
he's a genius.
He was a genius,
but you got to remember the Nikola Tesla
lived in a world where he was so far
ahead of the curve and there's very few
people that were able to compete with
them or even understand what he was doing.
Do you know that if you go to youtube and
you punch in Nikola Tesla hopes fraud,
nothing comes up. That's
amazing. That makes sense. Yeah.
And that's also a guy lives
1920 on the planet dispute.
Trying to say all that shit was bullshit.
There's no,
you go to youtube punching
Nikola Tesla hoax fraud.
Not One fucking video.
There's videos that come up that saying,
uh, something else was a
hoax. Nikola Tesla approves
it. Or you know, Nixon Nixon,
Tesla proves hoax,
but not one video of anybody
ever say Nikola Tesla.
I feel like,
but yeah,
but this is just the fact that
you can take it or leave it.
Put in Albert Einstein hoax fraud.
Endless videos. It's a bummer. It
was a free, yeah, it does videos.
They're like,
wait
a minute,
it's an Albert was an Albert Einstein.
Time magazine's man of the century.
Let me stop.
I thought he was the smartest man in
a second. Let me just help you here.
You're getting very dramatic. So let
me stop for a second. If you put,
if you put in Holocaust hoax,
you'll get an equal number of them.
I'm not talking about that. You
know, if you put in Sandy Hook hoax,
you're getting an equal number.
You get it.
You get a tremendous number
of people that think that
it's amazing.
Well all sign on him.
How about people that don't think
that Richard Pryor was genius prior?
Have you ever met a comic wants?
It doesn't think Richard Pryor is
one of the greatest of all time.
They don't exist to videos of people
trying to prove that he was wasn't the
greatest sound, but I mean, look, I
believe that snow melting on Nikola Tesla,
I don't think that Einstein was
a hoax dude. Causation though.
Shit, I'm not, I don't know nothing.
All I know is there's nothing on
Nikola Tesla doesn't mean anything,
but there's thousands of Albert
I you look into his life like,
Oh, anyone besides business
Tesla. Oh, does it have that?
Is he the only guy at Thomas Edison?
Thomas Edison was always
accused of stealing the ideas
of Nikola Tesla. In fact,
Thomas Edison electrocuted an elephant
in the middle of like, what was it,
the World Thomas. Oh, Thomas Edison.
Thomas Edison electrocuted
a fucking elephants.
There's video because he wanted to prove
that alternating and direct current
ACDC, which is Tesla's idea. There's
video of analysis for an electric heater,
not by Thomas [inaudible].
Thomas Edison did it.
The reason why he did it is to
prove what you tried to like.
It was propaganda against Tesla's ideas,
which are more advanced form
of movable like he wanted,
he wanted there to be alternating
currents and test test lesson was a direct
Einstein's. We're alive and
kicking at the same time. Tesla,
there's quotes.
The quotes could be bullshit.
You know Tesla comes from several dead.
He thought Einstein was a fraud.
That could be a phrase that I've heard.
I've heard that shit. But there are quotes
that can be bullshit of Tesla. There's,
I keep, they keep popping up breaking even
on it. Hold on, hold on. There's quotes.
Test the quotes saying the theory
of relativity is basically a joke.
There's tests. Haha. No, no. What
I'm saying is it could be bullshit,
but it keeps coming up when they're no,
we know that the theory of
relativity is used right.
So that we know that that's
not so much a theory anymore.
But here's what I think that
he's addressing. So Einstein,
from what I have read is
Einstein was a great mind,
but he was coming up at a time where
he got most of the credit he got.
He became very,
he became a famous scientist when there
were a lot of scientists working on very
similar, right? He was an average side.
So getting blown up and contributing
to the larger debate about, uh, um,
uh,
um, what does it need? Uh,
quantum physics, right.
And so there was also a big
debate about their methods,
whereas Tesla was a
big fan of experiments.
Einstein was a big fan of equations and
one of the big, quite a big criticisms,
one of the big quotes and say,
what are you pulling up today?
What does this Tesla's overrated
debunking Tesla, Tesla's a pop,
a figure and conspiracy culture. What
is, what is it saying? What is he saying?
He says, test. That's not even just
a conspiracy. What is he saying?
He sat right here. He says,
Tessa was a popular figure today,
but he's also a self publicist
and this stuff he didn't invent.
He did not event alternate and current.
Yeah,
he just was one of many people
working on it. Okay. What?
He's probably one of the four forefront.
Mine's right.
Being a showman helped popularize it too.
She's so good at that.
Eventually had to,
I don't know if he's right or not promise
and he said there was no one saying
anything against it,
but there is free energy and he's,
he's he 100% official story.
He's not against not w he doesn't
believe in that one conspiracy. You know,
you're right.
100% and that's one of my,
the only criticism that
had about that guy.
Like when we talked
about the Gulf of Tonkin,
he doesn't want to even admit
that Gulf was false flag
operation Northwoods. He was trying
to downplay, I'm like, look man,
whether or not you know what happened
in any other place, like you know,
the Joint Chiefs of Staff wrote down a
memo saying what the plan was to have
Guantanamo Bay attack by Cuban friendlies
that we're going to give them guns,
give them bombs, have them attack American
civilians. He's always like, well,
it never was implemented.
I was like, it's, it's, it
doesn't matter. They signed it.
Kennedy had a veto. Yes,
but Kennedy vetoed it.
That's why there's checks and
balances and in place like no, no, no.
The mindset behind the type of person
that would want to blow up Americans and
blame it on the Cuban so we could
justify the founding families.
There would always be people within the
government that would do anything they
could. And so that's where the
checks and balances of course,
they don't always go through
perfectly. That's, I mean if, if PR,
if Nixon was Reagan or,
I mean if it was rather if a Kennedy
rather was Reagan or Kennedy was Nixon,
he might very well have let that slide.
Who knows?
I mean a different person in a different
circumstance with a different view of
the world could have let the joint
chiefs of staff pull that through.
So that shows you the mindset,
right?
So the mindsets undeniable that people
absolutely do conspire. So when you,
a guy who never believed in conspiracies,
you do just as much damage
as a guy who always believed.
Alexander Hamilton said that it's not
just a king you have to worry about,
it's your actual government that's
been elected. So just because you,
your parliament,
he was using promise as an example.
Just cause problem was voted in,
doesn't mean that small group of people
will not get power hungry and trunk.
So therefore you've got to have
all these checks and balances.
You've got to have courts,
you've got all kinds of things and you
have to have a Senate and a house of
Representatives.
This is where these ideas came from.
That's what the of those fucking
guys, well it's the only thing right
now is keeping Trump from instituting.
He has traveled,
man do it a lot of [inaudible] still.
But even with those checks and balances,
he's still able to cut back
the EPA budgets. Democracy.
It was from the Paris climate agreement.
So there's a lot of weird shit that
goes on that they didn't anticipate us,
but what they didn't anticipate,
they did put enough checks and balances
that it's keeping from one person,
from just completely dominating the thing.
Because they came from monarchies.
Those guys,
they came from monarchies.
They knew that no matter who
you are as a human being,
whether you're democratically
elected or you're,
you're divinely elected like
the king wasn't in Europe,
you are going to take
advantage of your power.
You're going to get drunk with power.
It's very human and to want to have
control over other people and do for them
what what they don't know is best
for themselves. That's oral man.
Look at whether it's Libya or look at
North Korea or looking at people want to
dominate the people around them.
They've been doing it since
the beginning of time.
If you don't think they're doing it
right now, you're fucking crazy, right?
The question is what is the absolute
objective thing that's happening here?
Like the objective view
of what's happening here.
That's where it gets real
tricky for all of us.
Whenever we say we know
that something's happening,
there's no way you could know and I
know that there's no way you can know,
so now we have a really
tainted conversation because
we're not looking at this
whole thing. Honestly, whether it,
whether whatever the fuck it is,
whether it's aliens or life
after death or anything,
I need to absolutely fucking know
that you're being honest. Yeah,
and as soon as I don't think you are or
if I think you're trying to gain power,
if as soon as you see a politician give
some bullshit fucking speech where you
know that they're giving this cane,
this canned cadence,
this nonsense rhetoric,
and you knew as soon as they get into,
they're going to give into the fucking
special interest groups. That's right.
That's what Bush, it happens with
everybody. It happened with Obama.
That's why a free press,
that's why a free press from all
different angles is so important.
Uncensored press and that's why it's
called the fourth estate man that keeps
puking power in check. Transparency
does, and that's the other thing.
The other problem is that
when government grows,
which it always has a tendency
to do what does government do?
It taxes and passes laws to very coercive
measures. You keep growing government.
Here's what happens. It doesn't get more
powerful nest. It gets more powerful,
but also more people are dependent on it.
More people are feeding from the public
trough and then it becomes really hard
to get rid of it.
It's really hard to get rid of a
government program once it starts because
they're a cottage industry
grows up around it.
To me that's the big problem they
have right now with prisons. Yes.
There's so many fucking prisons.
And then they start prison
guard unions start passing laws.
They started lobbying to get laws
passed to keep marijuana illegal,
to make sure that their,
their prisons are filled because these
prisons become generators of money.
That's right. They don't become places
where PiCompany economies in slaved. Dude,
it's so,
so your politicians not going to say
anything that's going to get not grow that
industry. That's too much
pressure. As a politician,
you spend 40% of your time
raising money from strangers
for your next election. What about
that conspiracy theory about uh,
uh,
hip hop and rap,
gangster rap being created to promote um,
crime.
So conspiracy theory,
welfare is any loan in there,
long beach apartments trying to
figure it out or the private prisons.
People profiting off prisons.
Right.
If they have any connection to timeline.
Here's the problem with the timeline
there with the private prisons weren't
really that popular. Doctors, the
seventies prisons were popular.
Like the rap music really came up.
The original racing wasn't even,
but it wasn't even a real gangster rap.
It was gangsta rap. The way we're talking,
like when the Bronx was on fire,
I'll close to specifically gangsta rap.
That's
the conspiracy theory,
get to the next level and
that the gangster rap from
Compton and all that shit,
but he came from New York, man. It came
from when the Bronx was a game came from.
That's where we're asked to wrap though.
Came from rap came from New York.
That whole story with the security
deniable that like ice tea and Nwa and ice
cube. That's think about that to help him.
They would end up Niggas for lies and more
new. But yeah, you guys remember that.
The album Niggas for life,
that's what it was called.
The Mexican says,
no,
he can't kill hookers.
They had little skits in
between the songs and they,
they're at a song about a gang raping.
A 14 girl.
You go in a drive in that
day had a song about,
she swallowed it. It's called, she
swallow those 90 to half involved.
We fucking, how did they get away
with that? Because we hadn't evolved.
We didn't know what it meant.
Dude. Straight outta Compton
had killed the police.
You know. That's right. Fuck the pope.
Wasn't that when public enemy or is that,
that's Nwa. Public enemy had some harsh
songs. They got away with a lot of shit.
Fuck the police.
That's the worst thing you
could see at a concert saying,
fuck the police storm that you're jumping
when you talk about like the gangster
rap in La are kind of jumping up.
You're not gangster rap started
incompetent representing York because
there's sip up and then there's
gangster rap. It's ended up, you know,
as I'm shooting in La, I don't know man.
No you don't. But I'm out of
my lane. It started in college,
not talking about it. Bra 88.
Um, I got them about Pavarotti.
He had a song called the police.
He's not, he died. I've already died.
He was greatness. I saw him singing
person really live. Yes, I totally shit.
And he sang Nessun dorma which
you should really listen to it.
Nessun Dorma no one sleeps.
Listen please.
They no one sang at the met because
they couldn't hit that fucking dope.
They tell us not that his book go ahead,
hit. And I got good things to say.
That's a,
a play paradox.
You motherfuckers and the greatest
restaurant in the world via Veneto down in
fucking Venice. If you don't go
there, you're fucking lost show.
And this show, I can't, there's some
things I get obsessed with and that's it.
That's my restaurant and
fucking pub rock thing.
You fucking sell it out in Australia.
He's never been to Australia and started
to feel insecure so he gets shut off.
Sorry. Eastern. Hey, you're making
me feel you're triggering me dude.
I'm trying shell trial back in Calabasas.
You man,
shout out to Max Holloway.
Run in Hawaii with an iron fist.
Shout out to Max Holloway was bring
this bitch home. Hold on guys,
let me get this to the people watching.
How many people? 48,000 you Zit,
couple of people listening. Probably
less now. How many have we got? No,
probably less dropped us rise talk
now they'll, we had government talk,
we drop about 10. Sorry,
I brought to a halt.
Fox News kills
another trigger.
You motherfucker,
you're triggering 17 views.
He goes, no, I get why you would
read it. But Joe doesn't have that.
So why would you tell
people have stress?
They're listening.
I want to help you guys don't even
remotely commiserate. You're like, bitch,
I ain't got that problem.
Save that for Solo.
Oh God dammit.
We're gonna wrap this up.
But I want to say this.
Sometimes we have these
podcasts and she ain't,
shit gets crazy and we get heated and
we started smoking pot with drinking.
And there's like a,
a missing,
there's an a wrong impression
that some people get that window.
We love each other.
I have the best time.
You no matter what we agree or
disagree on, you know, I think it's uh,
it's important.
This is a family man.
I've,
I've had a lot of arguments with my
brother and my cousins and stuff and it's
like,
you know,
you are mad and you aren't going back
and forth and I'm like fuck that you said
that and he said this. But when
it, when it's all said and done man
it's good
cause I respect your opinion.
I respect your opinion.
I know Jamie,
I've got quite know all you guys.
I respect everyone in this room's opinion
and I think it's very important even
if you don't agree with someone's opinion
to be confronted by it because I think
if everybody just look,
we've all been around that one person
or many people like especially like old
time celebrities,
celebrities that are famous in like
the seventies and the 80s and shit when
there was no internet and then they,
this never felt this need to
check themselves. Sure. You know,
they were never informed.
And I think that one of the best things
about having a group of friends like you
guys and like all of our comedian and
I think all of our Jujitsu friends too.
And I think that's one of the things
that kind of ties it all together.
You get a different,
a different group of humans who,
who've experienced a lot of weird shit,
who,
a different group and you have a different
point of view than me on a lot of
shit. Whether it's MMA, whether it's,
um, I mean there's always, we always, we,
you and I have had spirited discussions
about shit that we agreed or disagreed
on the entire time we've been friends.
But you can do that and
still be cool to each other.
And I think that's
what's really important.
I think also the great thing
about friendships after you
get to be my age anyway,
and you spend a lot of time with people,
is that this is getting very,
I want some violin music,
but this is serious
music coming up. You're coming up now.
Here's what I want to say. Hey man,
you gotta be frank there. Gets it.
They get to a point with friendship.
You know where I was
thinking about this with you,
like you could do pretty much anything.
You're never not going to
be my friend no matter what.
The only thing that would maybe question
is if you heard a child, God forbid,
or if you were drawing animals in
your basement, then I'd be like,
ah fucking guy. But you
know what I mean, guys,
don't help you bury somebody back.
Exactly. That's exactly right. Feet
touching her breasts.
There's only,
I mean there's a fucking small handful
of people that I would call if I murdered
somebody there in this room. Yeah, I
would, I would. It'd be a burner. Call me.
Don't call you. Call the loyal dog first.
Cause I do it. Listen, we're all fucking,
he'd get scared and go, I have a
tummy ache. I got a tummy ache.
But Malibu was only six months old
electrical class. My dog's afraid
and living to do root cause.
The first guy you call
your dog right here.
Last time we did one of these podcasts,
got 10 million downloads, Chris,
the last time.
It's probably the biggest thing other
than the Alex Jones episode number one,
number one, and Alex Jones is
one of the Alex Jones episodes,
one of the best pieces of evidence that
there's some potential opening for some
sort of a conspiracy to keep some people
down because the Alex Jones episode,
not only did he get more downloads
in any podcast we've ever done ever,
but he got more by like
what 4 million deep state,
the deep state cooking, lots of silence
him. It's up to 15 million, but no,
here's what they did do and
I don't think that they look,
it could be catastrophic coincidence,
but during the time when the ounce Jones
episode wet running through the charts
of our art, like downloads, we
get like if I have a number,
like this is my number one,
this is my number two,
the Alex Jones is 5 million
downloads ahead of everything.
Now here's the crazy thing.
Itunes ratings went down and I
don't think they went down on focus.
I don't think they went down on
purpose, right? Lead just his ears.
They coincidentally,
this is what's undeniable.
They coincidentally went down the very
time that the Alex Jones podcast was
rampaging through the tribe state.
Now my podcast oftentimes reached number
one on the iTunes charts in terms of
like the podcast episodes.
Oftentimes if it's a real,
if it's Lawrence Krauss or Sam Harris
or you know, maybe even this, this way.
So when that does happen, I've
got to say Whoa, fuck podcast.
Got 5 million downloads more
than any podcast I've ever done.
Ever. Yeah, for sure.
That one's going to be number one
and not only was it not number one,
but hold on, hold on. Here we got here.
Itunes is being gangster honors
about, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Shut the fuck up. What Jamie currently
number three and four overall. Okay.
We are our pot.
The episodes to Alex Jones podcast never
got past like number 20 or so crazy.
Yeah.
Not only that,
but the ones after it and the ones before
they got way less downloads were all
ranked higher. All rank tires.
Do you think it's because,
because I listened to that and you guys
got so fucking crazy towards the end
dimensional shot molester. You guys got,
you all got Hillary completely nuts.
I had, I had turned you
guys off. I listened to two
hours and I was like, well,
now we're in killed.
Get good until hour three. It was not,
not try this now almost three hours.
I was like, oh no, my God, I think people
turn, they went to, they're too drunk.
You guys got too drunk and be honest
with you, got too high and dry was fine.
People got pissed. People, God, whoever.
I had so much heat and publicly
Cholos and shit got mad at me.
Gangbangers gangbanger got fucking man,
Alex Jones Kid. He started thinking,
he started going, he'd go like
metallic Tara. Tara Trump told me,
and then you guys just go off on
another fucking tell us about that.
But he was high. But that's what
Alex, Alex, to tell you one subject,
they'll turn corners.
George Soros making the marijuana stronger
and then next thing you know if the
astronauts really did lay on the front,
but the problem was they found aliens.
They're like, hey, hey, hey,
hey. Have you ever seen,
he goes back and forth and back and back.
Damn,
he got you. Hey, sit
back. Wait, wait, wait.
Stop it this whole time. This whole
time. I'm the crazy motherfucker
and I go,
one of these days,
he's been friends with Alec Johnson's
fucking 1998 he should've been on Alex
Jones. Should have been on
episode three or four or five.
We ended up being 911 finally,
I waited all this time.
I knew what I was go this time. I go,
oh, should I even asked Janko Dude,
let me fucking jump on that bitch. I had
a, I never knew that. I never do that.
I did that for Paul Stanley
and kiss shit didn't work out,
but I was in town and I said, I can't
make it. I'm going to be out of town.
But it turned out you were good
though. But anyways, I showed up and,
and I'm thinking finally,
someone else is going to just talk for me.
And for the first hour I didn't
say shit right and doing nothing.
I didn't say nothing. I didn't say
you're an augurous chem trail. Shit.
[inaudible] and me and Alex Jones have
talked about chem trails and he knows so
he knows a thousand times more
about chem trails than I do.
He has the documents memorized in his
head. He's got a photographic memory.
So I finally wanted, I finally
talked after an hour and let him go.
He wowed the whole world.
Everyone's like, oh shit. Oh Shit,
we're getting fucked here
we are getting fucked.
And then I decided to bring
the chem trails up and he
didn't want to talk about,
he want to talk about Trump,
you want to keep going on Trump.
And I wanted to go chem trails and I
kinda, I got Kinda pissed, you know,
and I was like, fuck, I've been waiting
this whole fucking time. Why do you,
why are you so obsessed with chem trails?
What is it about chemistry?
It's just scared air. It's
just hair. I don't know.
It's just there for some
reason I think airs important.
10 25 I've got to get out of here. I've
got a spot at the store. You got a spot,
a spot store.
Anybody working tonight?
You guys work in Australia tomorrow
night when he didn't Sydney and Auckland.
Hold on. When are you doing? Stand
up, you know you're doing stand up.
We've got to do to make this happen. I'm
ready to go. Five minutes. All right.
All the time.
I told Sam tripling.
I go do put me on a secret
little tiny up belly room show.
Don't I just want to go up there?
I don't want to tell me about,
we've got five minutes.
Do a Wednesday.
I do Wednesdays to the
ice house all the time.
Next Wednesday I'd do with the Ice House.
Go Up, commit to them and I'll put it,
we'll figure it out this
Wednesday. But book plenty.
Top five minutes. Normal. Yes,
totally normal cause I know on on come on.
Um,
three, three, the open mic night. I got
the comedy store. Ladies and gentlemen.
That's it. Yeah. Sydney,
Australia, Melbourne,
Australia, Sydney and Auckland. New
Zealand only tickets left defect. gay.com
fuckers. Fucking amazing class.
It's Robert. What's going on?
You know what?
I got a mixed fleet coming out and
mixed flick of death and devotion.
It's a compilation of a bunch of music
videos based on the best movies ever.
Drop in Tuesday on my youtube channel.
Check it out,
talking shit and telling jokes till the
air stops coming out. See you soon. Bye.